generally with me today is Ferg and we
are fighting and braving the African
weather just to be able to go and find
some animals now if you've got any
comments or any questions please send
them through using the hash tags by lab
or use the YouTube chat we are not too
sure where we're headed we want to go
perhaps see the last area where the
tracks were in in this morning for
attack of wild ducks we've perhaps by
any miracle they've come back and I
think that's our plan for the afternoon
other than that perhaps we'll head later
on to see good old boat in Ghana the
male leopard hopefully well he will be
roughly in the same area where we saw
him this morning and we'll be able to
share some time with him now I'm hoping
that'll be the case and other than that
like I say just braving the wind that we
were scheduled to do a walk this
afternoon but it is the windy conditions
often make it very dangerous so we've
decided against it just because of our
general safety now as you can see the
wind all around us if you look at all
all the grass you can see how
everything's moving all the trees all
the branches now the weather has been
quite puzzling and we had this massive
storm predicted for today lots and lots
of rain but as a day has gone through we
still haven't had any drops which is a
good and a bad thing so I wonder if
perhaps later on during this afternoon
we're gonna get all that rain really
interesting to see although you're ready
for the rain Ferg and I we've got all of
our rain gear so we're not scared we
will brave the weather as as well as the
Impala I hope they were being paid
clever and we just went past one
breeding herd and they were all tucked
away in the bushes all standing together
trying to seek or find some shelter from
all this all this wind and the possible
gloomy weather ahead now there is a blue
sky to our right so towards the east so
I am hoping that the beautiful blue
skies are gonna carry with us for the
rest of the afternoon and I think we are
actually going to start driving onto the
blue skies that sounds like a wonderful
plan for the afternoon we'll just
pretend and go leave the dark skies
ahead of us behind us so that way we
won't even see them
right seems like Tristan is looking up
at some track so let's head back to him
and find out what he's after I am
looking at tracks I'm looking at tracks
of probably one of the biggest snake
tracks that I've seen since I've been at
Juma this is seriously large as you can
see it it's kind of twisting its way I
don't know what the word would be sort
of going from side to side across the
road you can see the big mounds of sand
being pushed away from the backside and
going so the snake was moving towards us
with the sand being pushed away from us
a little bit and so what I wanted to
show you is just how thick this snake
track actually is it looks about the
size of my forearm so where's a good
clear one here VM let's do this side so
if I have to put my forearm inside there
there we go it fits just right so my
form would fit inside of that section
right there which is well there we go
that's House wide that snake is that
gives you an idea of how thick the snake
is and how big it is now snakes that get
this thick are very few and far between
there's only probably three candidates
that we could take for this one would be
a puff adder the other one would be a
Python of some size I mean that wouldn't
be the biggest Python but it would be a
Python or a incredibly large Black Mamba
would be the other option but given the
small gate of the twist and turn it
probably in all likelihood is a very big
puff adder puff adders gets a wide wide
wide body and that small kind of gate
like that would be a short snake but
very wide but still amazing to see now
it's gone towards a little section here
behind me that's fallen over trees and
stumps and these tracks are actually
funny enough on top of our vehicle
tracks wavy came down just now which was
not long ago maybe about 45 minutes ago
so I want to just check back here and
see maybe we get lucky and we can
actually find the snake and track it
down probably went in somewhere here
lots of little snake hidey holes here
this little termite mound that it could
have gone in
so captain awesome you say please go
look for the snake well I mean we can't
try and track it down of course it's
going to go to a certain point and I
think it's probably going to hide away
if it's something like a Python then
they go underground quite a lot so
they'll find a termite mom into the
termite man and hide out something like
a Mamba is going to be very quick and
move off up into the trees and gonna be
quite tough to find puff adder is
probably our best bit in terms of
actually finding the snake we would have
to walk through this grass and look very
very carefully and try and see if I can
spot it somewhere here but they also
will get in under things and get into a
place where they can hide you might find
because of this temperature change that
we're getting in this wind that's
blowing maybe the snake is on the move
and just trying to find a better more
sheltered area in order to spend the day
but I'll try and follow the track now
and just see where it goes and try and
work out exactly the point that it
disappears if I can follow the track I
should be able to work it out and see if
it's gone into the ground or something
like that if it's gone into a mount
obviously I'm not going to be putting my
hands down there or doing anything like
that and I don't really want to get a
surprise from a member or apathetic you
very much they are not very pleasant
snakes to deal with sometimes so I'm
going to try and just have a little look
around see if I can find it for you and
see if we can get some sort of semblance
of view of the snake the problem with
that is that I'm going to need to track
it Kirsty so I'm not going to be able to
do that while I'm live because I'll have
to follow it via my feet and that means
that I'm not going to be able to really
talk to you guys or see what you see so
I'll have to just try and reverse a
little bit first and see what I can see
with the camera ah
so we've got no signal with Byron and
Ellie's got low signal so you're all
stuck with me I don't have to do this
with a vehicle let's see if I can manage
this with a car and this should be quite
interesting
okay there's lots of little hidey holes
here VM did you see exactly where that's
crossed
I'm trying to look if I can see the
snake track on the ground itself we
obviously don't want a situation so it
came along there and it came straight to
AVM is saying just on my left hand side
I wonder if it didn't go into this
little termite mound yeah there's a
little hole that is straight down let's
have a little look oh that's rather deep
there's a movie a lot warmer than what
it is Archer this cold wind has come and
so for a snake going inside there's me
like a little oven and keep them nice
and warm and if you're a cold-blooded
animal warmth is what you want that
keeps you active and able to then hunt
and find food so think that's where it's
gone I just want to do a little loop
around the bush on the left or the
southern side and see if I can see
anything obviously also don't want to
drive over the snake of course the snake
will move it's not going to say stole
but but like I say the track is very
very fresh it's from 45 minutes ago it
may be even later that's just the kind
of time frame we've got to work with so
I mean if that was a leopard track there
would be as fresh as you could possibly
ask for and you would bet your bottom
dollar you would find it but a snake is
a completely different story looks like
your you might have some company if it's
continued all the way through mmm going
to be very tough to find it in this I
don't think unfortunately we're gonna
get those rides with that termite mound
there I think it's gone straight down
inside I mean there's no sign of its
anywhere I can see in these trees when
we should be able to spot it quite
quickly if it was like that so
unfortunately we're going to have to
abandon that search for now and brave
the winds of jummah
Tenace in terms of tracking hardest
things to track and it depends on what
we're talking about you know you've got
species like the big animals which
undoubtedly the hardest big animal to
track is leopard by far it's why when
you do your tracking assessments leopard
is the one that you follow in order to
become the highest level of tracker that
you can be so you have to find the
footprint of a lipid and follow it and
try and find that animal so in terms of
big animals I would say them in terms of
smaller animals well I mean there's a
lot of different ones there's things
like wasps that collect mud or spiders
or crickets scorpions those minut little
tracks and because they don't really
leave big sort of traces on ground other
than them crossing roads or pathways
it's almost impossible to follow their
tracks so you'll find those very tough
and what else is a difficult animal to
track things that move very fast and
very far so while dogs are tough to
track hyenas is funny enough or are not
easy either and that's also because of
the amount of hyenas archers often
criss-crossing of tracks which makes it
very difficult what else that's about it
the rest of the big animals elephants
buffalo rhinos they fairly simple in
terms of the tracking process they leave
big signs for you and the nice thing
with them is that they leave very large
areas where they've fed so it's not only
their footprints but it's also where
they've fed and broken branches pull
that grass and those kind of things now
VM has spotted a little surprise in the
graphs there so it's very well
camouflaged but there's a little scrub
here that's come out quite early enough
probably because the cards are out it's
a bit dingy already this afternoon and
so a perfect time for a scrub here just
to come out and nibble which you can see
the nocturnal and why they are so
successful at being nocturnal look at
the size of the eyes and the ears in
relation to their body massive massive
massive eyes big ears that allow them to
hear and see what's going on even in the
dark of night and so they can thrive in
that way they've also got a very
sensitive nose that
except a lot of cent but this poor
animal will probably be as petrified as
it looks it looks very wide eyed at the
moment and that's because of all of this
wind it's not going to be an easy night
for any of the prey animals when it's
windy like this the the Predators have
an absolute field day and they can get
stuck into all of these prey animals and
it makes it much harder for the prey
animals to be sort of find out where the
Predators are wind swirls noise and
those kind of things but did you see how
well of camouflage is amazing that the
camouflage that these little guys have
good little scrub here stay safe be
careful I saw a martial eagle flying
around jail earlier so scrub Hays in
danger from Marshal Eagles I must be a
little careful of them seems a little
quieter today around it doesn't seem to
be all the Ellie's and I'm not surprised
elephants hate wind so in the wind kicks
up like this thing is into the thickets
as quick as possible just to get out of
the breeze that's blowing and they try
and kind of stay as sheltered protected
as possible so much surprise we're not
seeing too many elephants around them
the afternoon we're gonna try to find
tiny VM and I are going to try and find
tiny that's what we going to go into so
we're going to sit out into the eastern
south east and beyond and try and see if
we can find this lipid and we've been
hiding and while we do that it sounds as
though Byron tardy surrou has got his
speedos sorted out he's tucked his shirt
in he's all sorted and is now ready to
finally join us for the afternoons drive
oh that's not very fair trust
I am I I do apologize for being late but
good afternoon my name is Byron and on
camera with me as sensor and what a good
start I found a big bull elephant now
this one looks rather large it's going
to have a look it's very very windy
I know Tristan has been telling you
about it but wow it's a
how the weather's changed winds actually
blowing from that elephant to us wow
this is a big bull good look at this
male and see his reaction to the vehicle
wonderful this is a great start for me
you all know how much I enjoy spending
time with these big elephant seems very
relaxed
I wonder if this isn't the that elephant
that's got a hole in his ear can you see
other sins oh no on his right yeah let's
see sorry the other one it's just not
turning enough I don't see a hole not so
it's not the elephant that Tyler knows
as Darrell but he is a large male
enjoying the fruit at the moment so many
fruit care I'm just gonna sit still and
see if the smell decides to come over
closer to us it could be
could be really entertaining I'm sure I
saw this mail the other day because
they've got a prominent to hold in his
left ear small little one and he looks
and he looks he looks similar I'm not
sure that there are a lot of elephant
that come through this area Bobby I'm
not sure the largest elephant I've seen
I did see a one or two really old Bulls
on London lazy a few years ago passing
through and and some samples as one male
really really old male that had these
massive tusks they almost touched the
ground when he walked and that doesn't
magnificent to see so at once but I've
definitely seen Bulls a bit bigger than
this okay I'm gonna sit quietly let's
see what this male does is he gonna come
closer
I'm sure he's enjoying there's a cool
breeze at the moment
is not showing any signs of aggression
seems very relaxed all right I must be
honest I really do feel privileged when
we get to sit with with these
magnificent beasts to think this
elephant is probably thirty of maybe
even closer to 40 years old it's quite a
large male a [ __ ] he's got some amazing
stories growing up in the greater Kruger
now my plan this afternoon is actually
to go to those lions that in Kakuma
Pride I'd like to try to get there
fairly soon because it is quite cool
maybe we're lucky and they start moving
around
apparently Justin said they would look
quite hungry this morning
who knows
perhaps as Lions decide to get up and
move I think we'll leave this
magnificent bull wonderful start for us
I saw that snake track that Tristan was
looking at that was that was amazing I
wonder wonder where that snake
disappeared to because that was a really
large track ok let's go I'm gonna go and
look for those lines let's go to Ellie
who's heading down to children we are
and we've taking a bit of a detour we've
decided to take the northern boundary
then go down to to cut line just to see
what's been happening around here
obviously all in the hopes of finding
time but perhaps somewhere to approach
to open a morula tree although chances
of any leopard being on top of a morula
tree today I I would say a little bit
slim just because it is so windy so if
it's very windy and our vehicle level I
would imagine that on top of a morula
it's even worse so likely they're all
gonna be doing the same thing as Dingaan
I was doing today and they're gonna be
down on the ground probably hidden
tucked away in the bushes
while they stalk something or where they
carry on with their afternoon nap
now we haven't really seen all that much
up here oh you couldn't even pick up
tracks for Tomba so I think he's
probably stole somewhere in both aw
shucks probably trying his luck he was
hunting yesterday so I'm hoping he
managed to get something perhaps a tiger
or see amok that would have stint still
being a good meal for him now there's
always the hope that they all of the
leopards are gonna catch something
bigger this afternoon because it is very
windy and it seems like this type of
weather condition is normally favorable
for the Predators to catch something
so we'll see I think maybe tomorrow
morning or the day after that's when
we'll really be able to see what's been
happening after the night because that's
when they're gonna have the premium
advantage all of these beautiful I think
we're gonna go past happening you know
might be coming down to the water and
last we went there which was hippos
which was there's a normal good ol
friend and the other one who I don't
know who it is while we get to both dam
though we're gonna head back to I
believe is on the lionsearch
I am indeed on the lionsearch let's see
I think they were around here some way
since I let's keep our eyes peeled now
again this wither is tricky because they
may have already got up and started
moving which would make it a bit harder
for us to find them
so we I'm just gonna scan very very
carefully as you go through here I think
they were around here this morning have
a look obviously a lot of vehicles have
been three already in the course of the
day so it would be difficult to find
fresh tracks of them hitting the swim
maybe maybe if they've started to move
we might find fresh tracks of them
moving this afternoon
I don't think our birding is going to be
very good this afternoon
generally when it's very very windy like
us then the birding is not great
I'm trying to have a look and see if I
can find any sign of these lions
anything yet since I
right
I think Tristan mentioned something that
they were near the old hi Nadine which
is which is ratchet line there we go
there we go
fantastic let's have a quick look see
what the prod is up to see a few heads
up already this is great well that is
wonderful no yep couple of heads up and
then some lying down not moving Oh
wonderful
it looks like the whole pride is here I
can just see some of them are behind
some trees I don't think you'll you'll
see them but this is much better weather
for potential movement compared to
yesterday afternoon when we were sitting
with that sticks pride the other pride
of lions
remember how how hot it was yesterday
afternoon and and those lions hardly
moved they moved out of the drainage
line where they were all that dry
riverbed and went and lay on the bank
and just carried on sleeping it was so
hot I think I probably only got active
much later now there's a very cool
breeze and also with it being so windy
these might be good conditions for these
lines to hunt so possibly if we're lucky
we're gonna be patient we're gonna sit
with these Lions maybe we get them
getting up moving around and possibly
trying to hunt a bit later but for now
they are resting so we're gonna sit
tight let's go across to Ellie who is
apparently heading towards the dam
well we are and we have arrived unto
Bufo sack damn and much to our surprise
there is not one hippo but three of them
now the I'm not too sure which one is
our good old friend that's normally in
here I am slightly tempted to say that
it's not the one that is standing on top
of the water just because I can't seem
to remember that discoloration behind
its ear perhaps I just haven't noticed
perhaps this is the same one but it's
quite interesting to see that there are
two more around here what it could be is
perhaps the two young bulls have come
into this particular waterhole looking
for a place to to conquer a new area
maybe they've come all the way from
chittor Dam maybe they've come from one
of the dams and buffers look there are
quite a few dams all around us and it
wouldn't be surprising if they started
moving in this weather just looking for
new places now there has been a little
bit of display involved the big bowl
that's in there has been opening his
mouth there's been a little bit of
defecating and spraying of their dung
which is normally all done on a show of
type of thing just to advertise that
he's the big one and he is the owner of
this particular area now the little bird
behind it is a little green which
obviously now I decided to try and fly
again for the win which is not working
too well
for it and then we've got this three
very puzzling I'm hoping that they're
gonna do something as well they were a
little bit more active a few moments ago
so we're gonna stand still and just see
if perhaps they get off to what they
were doing earlier on now I wouldn't be
surprised if these guys only arrived
today because yesterday afternoon I mean
Byron and I were here and they were
definitely only two of them in there so
there's a newcomer and perhaps that's
what's throwing a bit of a spanner in
the works and altering them
first lady yes if ou do made underwater
and their calves are also able to suckle
underwater which is quite interesting of
in terms of all the things that hippos
can do 108th order but yes they do it
under the water I'm not too sure these
guys are even interested in that and I
think that middle one I want to say that
he's a new one and he's a much older
bull in comparison to the other two that
we're seeing here I'm assuming they are
bulls because they don't have little
ones attached to them but I don't know
seems like seems Auden seems like new
things are starting to change with this
wind are you going to tell them who's
the boss definitely approaching one of
the youngsters a little bit of tension
going on they're gone all the way down
in the water okay
there's a bit of submissive behavior
normally when animals make themselves
either look smaller or where they put
their heads down it's a way of admitting
almost a defeat in terms of territorial
of hierarchy of dominance as in a way of
saying fine I know you're the boss let's
be nice
you're in command so I think perhaps
that's weed what we just witnessed is
one to the left a little bit smaller
than the one on the ride just putting
his head down and me like fine you you
are the boss just we're fine
don't worry about it now I was hoping
that he was gonna come out and open his
mouth and show his big tusks to us but
it doesn't seem like he wants to do it
just yet fail I'm not sure if hippos
ever drawn perhaps if they can even
David Kurtz if they cannot get to you to
the surface and get air and I'm pretty
sure that would cause them to drown it's
part of the reason also why they seem to
prefer areas where the current is very
slow and normally if there's a pod with
babies they either prefer lakes or rocky
areas but you'll never find them in a in
a river that's flowing also quickly
probably because if they cannot fight
the current to try and get to the
surface to get air yes they could
potentially drown
in this particular case I'm pretty sure
that their standing or lying I don't
think before the dam is that deep I
think it has gotten in the surface
otherwise I wouldn't be able to have as
much of their body exposed and out and
about
seems like Tristan has found a creature
that is perhaps just as pretty as a
hippo so let's head over and see well I
think it's a fake contest between the
two of them so hippo versus war talk
whether I feel like I would give hippo a
cuter factor than a wart ogres fish I
suppose maybe baby warthogs aren't too
bad but these guys these big male
warthogs are not the prettiest things in
the world you can see they've got big
big warts on them which is how I know
that they're both boys as well as well
you can see the male testes underneath
the tail of the one facing away from us
and the one on the far side is a little
skittish the one closest to us is not
too bad it doesn't worry about us too
much but you can see that one's keeping
a beady eye on us and is covered in ox
Pickers at the moment both of them and
so these guys I'm sure getting quite a
bit of food and off go the warthogs
trotting away everything's going to be a
little bit like this I think
everything's gonna be a bit shy a bit
reclusive when the wind is howling the
way that it is this afternoon most of
our prey animals are going to be a
little worried about some predators and
therefore gonna be a lot more shy than
they normally are so it'll be I think a
day like this way we're gonna get brief
views of our antelope species before
they trot off and try and get away from
where we are sitting in case there is a
predator around now we've just driven a
sneaky little routes along the moola
wotty all the way from just south of the
dam wall and then down towards Telepan
just in the hope that we maybe pick up
some sign of techne moving around in the
Milwaukee maybe she's kind of moved back
into the section and just keeping a low
profile but nothing there's not a single
track for a female leopard inside there
that I picked up and we looked quite
nicely and we checked all the spots that
she's used before with this cub there's
no sign of her visiting any of those
areas so she's not this size she must be
further to the east and I think maybe
she's spending
but more time on Torchwood then we
actually realize at the moment so I'm
gonna just kind of check you out Stan
quickly down to ten downs and then we're
gonna really work the eastern side quite
heavily for turn any sign of tummy so
drive around we'll try and listen out
for some alarm calls I'm hoping because
it's over the cost like this that if she
is around that she's an up and moving
or maybe she's hoisted a kill or
something if the conditions from last
night's was suitable for hunting I'm
pretty sure Tandy will take an advantage
of it so go and check around there and
just have a little look and see what's
going on so that's the idea anyway
hopefully it's all work outs and we will
find her somewhere in this area with the
little cub it's been so long since I've
seen that little cub I'm pretty sure it
must be about triple the size that it
was previously uh it's going to be a bit
of a shock I think when we see it
hopefully it's doing well and everything
is okay and that it's managing to avoid
this drama that is the male lipids of
the northern sabi sands at the moment
good talking about sort of drama and
things like that well Byron is sitting
with the Inca Huma pride and I wonder if
there'll be any drama this afternoon
with the pride hunting well at the
moment it doesn't look like it now I'm
trying to make a decision here I think
it might be worth us driving around a
little little bit and then coming back
in about half an hour or so because
there hasn't been much movement and
possibly these lines are still just
trying to rest
you can see that that wound on that line
s but it's not looking bad but it still
that's not ideal
pralaya nice that's you know that don't
know actually don't know what caused
that we know would I would assume it was
from hunting something
I'm sure you can hear the wind at the
moment and it's quite quite strong I
don't know if it's going to rain this
afternoon maybe this evening maybe this
brings in the storm often if it is very
windy it could just be very windy and
not rain so I'm not sure but I was
speaking about it earlier in bed where
the lacquers or when it rains lions and
leopards often do go out and hunt it's a
little bit easier for them to hide
mosques they smell the sound everything
so they can stalk up really close and
hunt whatever it is they're looking for
I think you know and I think I'm going
to leave these lines I'm not gonna sit
here now for too long but I will come
back a little bit later I just think it
for the moment they seem quite relaxed
very comfortable I'm possibly just
trying to conserve some more energy
until a little bit later so let's drive
around a bit it'd be fun I'm gonna check
some clearings you never know you could
get quite a bit of general game in that
area now especially because of all this
wind but let's see what else we can find
in the meantime I think rather than
sitting here with these sleeping lions
for too long I hope all of you having a
wonderful weekend wherever you are in
the world
as has been great actually has been
lovely nice and relaxing today
as I said I don't think our
bird-watching will be very good today
because of this were went oh wow at
least found something really small she
wants to show you we did it's the
smallest cutest little scrub here now
it's it's about the size of the palm of
my hand I would just see you know and I
don't want to get too close because it
might start running away but I wonder
why it is in the middle of the road you
should go and hide in the bushes a bird
of prey is gonna find you there we go no
you have to carry on running you didn't
run far enough and you're still on the
road beautiful little thing now during
the day likely they spend most of their
day they don't burn alike like rabbits
do but rather they go into basic
vegetation especially underneath thorny
trees or thorny bushes where it might be
harder for any potential predator to get
to them why this little one has decided
to be in the middle of the road in such
a windy day when pretty much a lot of
things can get it I'm not too sure for
house did God flush from where it was
hiding due to something else walking
around but you're not in the safest
place look at that
fluffy little white tail running around
that was super cute that was very
special
paulla yes that was super tiny that was
very very cute it was about the size of
my hand I would say without the ears
obviously but about something like that
so so cute wonder where it's gone off to
now now it's very thick in this general
direction when where it ran so I would
assume that perhaps it's gone back to
those bushes back to where the yellow
flowers are that's a raisin bush so
maybe it's hiding in there because it's
quite pushy very complicated to get in
if I wear a little scrub here that's
probably where I would be hiding that
was a very cool little find it's amazing
how sometimes the wind confuses them and
it brings out the rest or some
unexpected things unto the road I hope
big that this will be the day where we
also get a Pangolin and a caracal they
can all be in the same sighting I will
not complain if they all are but that
was very sweet
now here's our mostly nocturnal animals
so the fact that we've seen it out and
about during the day it's also a bit of
a strange thing and this little one it
has got to be careful if it once do you
have a good chance at making into
adulthood because it might not be the
best thing to be out in the middle of
the road during the day
joy its mother it's probably somewhere
else they they developed quite quickly
when they're little so very likely its
mother it's just away doing its own
thing and they don't spend all their
time with the little ones when they're
tiny obviously the mother and where
they're about this big the mothers will
come and suckle them a few times and
then go in forage and so on but I think
this one is probably already on its own
or if not on its own at least if the
mother has gone in a certain direction
and that one has been left behind as it
would normally happen perhaps another is
not too far away hiding somewhere else
and this one was just being probably a
naughty teenager and going out of the
house before it should monster party I
was in the wind now what are these
tracks over here
seems like I'm imagining things because
there are no trucks on the road maybe
that was just wishful thinking should
have actually stopped in most of the
tiny little scrubby here tracks but I
didn't think of it and talking about
tracks and little things let's head back
to Tristan who I believe is looking for
leopards I am indeed looking for a
spotted cat somewhere so far no signs or
any tracks that will indicate that there
is a spotted cat around but you can
always live in hope mostly just looking
for anything else really I just kind of
puttering about and I believe Ellie was
telling me today that she had tracks for
a male lion somewhere around for the
ones cutline Rebecca's area and that the
sticks have a random male lion lying
with them now I'm not sure who the male
line is or what his story is but
apparently the sticks seem completely
unfazed by this male lions
presence and the other thing about it is
that he apparently has got some really
nasty fresh wounds that have been
created now Ellie told me that when she
saw the tracks this morning that there
was places where there was tracks for
male line and blood drops on the road
and so I wonder if the birmingham's
didn't get hold of him last night and
that there's another male line that's
still sitting somewhere on Juma so just
kind of wanting to try and see if I can
find those tracks and just see how much
blood was on them I think Ellie sitting
is somewhere on Rebecca so I might have
missed him but let's just see how we go
I'm going down towards tree house I know
she said it was some tracks that came
from Chios here they are here but
they've been so driven over by vehicles
gonna be very difficult to make them out
pretty
these are tracks also for the in Coomer
pride so it seems as though maybe this
male bumped into another male maybe even
the in Kahuna pride who knows what's
happened to him but apparently has got
some nasty cuts and scrapes on him now
it's an interesting situation because I
would have thought if it was a random
male lion that the sticks didn't know
given that they've got cubs and they're
on a water bike kill that they would be
less than friendly towards an intruding
male and that they would try and chase
him away as quick as possible but he
seems to be just sitting there and they
not too concerned about it he's just
kind of sitting off to the side and
everything is okay so I for a second
thought I wonder if it's maybe not one
of the sticks male lions that they used
to be around this area
when was it it was back in I can't even
remember now 2015 was it's 2014 2015
they were the two young sticks boys that
were around and I wonder if it's not one
of them bears I think the same male line
that was seen on on Kirkman's down in
the south of the sabi sands recently I
actually have a photo of him some way
I'll try and find it a very pretty
looking line so I'll be a bit sad if he
got beaten up because he looks really
quite nice and unfortunately though this
is the trials of being Archer as a young
male lion is that you've got many many
many different coalition's to deal with
and it would be the first line that's
really come into this area since the
birmingham's are taken over and the
first one that's probably been dealt
with that by the barians property but if
it's this guy then it'll be interesting
this is the one that was seen down on
Kirkman's I'm not 100% sure if he's the
same one that was seen with the sticks
last night but maybe some of you out
there that have an idea of who this line
could be we'll give you another photo of
him there is so there we go that's the
photos of the guys from Kirkman's that
they sent to us to try and ask now Karen
you say that it could be the ginger
Matilda that could be with the sticks
interesting I I'm not 100% sure well I
guess I'll try and ask the guys if it's
an older line maybe it is I'm not sure I
know that the the older male will
ginger member of the of the members has
broken apart from Harry Billie's been
left in the Kruger somewhere and very
badly injured and he's kind of moved on
but this Lyme is a much younger
individual that was seen and this was
taken three days ago down on southern
Mala Mala and so if that comes straight
north
pretty much puts it righteous wonder if
it's maybe the matumbo or it's is this
individual but if somebody saw photos
and is the matte umber that'll be quite
cool to know interesting that it's back
in this area and surely not a good sign
for that individual because I'm sure the
birmingham's will try and get hold of
him if he is around yeah and like I said
he's got some nasty cuts apparently on
his forearms at all very fresh and
bleeding and then apparently lots of
flies on his back so maybe it is the
Matunga
may I know they got into a fight
recently Dean towards the end of last
year and just inside the Kruger with
some other males and I think they both
took a bit of a battering in that so we
just interesting to see how this all
plays out and whether or not that
midsummer makes another appearance on a
live Drive you is the two of them were
such a big part of safari life when it
first got back up and running in Douma
and the many of you will remember lots
of very fond sightings of those two
massive boys walking around yeah they
really were impressive specimens both of
them were incredibly large that the
track size of those two males was much
bigger than what we see from these
birmingham's at the moment so always
remember those two Fondy and they
certainly did a good job here for a
while but it was just never gonna work
two against five when the birmingham's
arrived
now triage them not really much
happening store hasn't produced many
leopard sightings this summer it's
interesting how winter
tree arson twin dams were just absolute
gold for lipids now in the summer it
just goes to show the lipids do not use
these dams nearly as much because
there's really so much water everywhere
that there's no point for them to come
to a big dam and lie explain so close
but in winter and there's no water they
have to come here and they become
hotspots for leopard so nothing really
much happening at tree house I'll carry
on and see what else we can find I see
there's the impalas
yep now from our impalas that tree
assets are looking a bit petrified to go
down to the water
it seems you across to Byron who's got
some others that hopefully look a little
calmer than these ones well it's very
very windy but what I wanted to show you
is exactly what I thought was gonna
happen we're gonna get to these
clearings and we're gonna see loads of
animals or just Impala but animals
aren't in the clearing look how close
all these Impala are together and a
whole herd is staying very very close to
one another because they know these
conditions make it very difficult to
listen out for predators or smell
predators so I'll stay a lot closer and
be very very aware of what is going on
around them but it makes sense for him
to stay in the clearing I can keep a
lookout for any potential danger just
before that just saw some other movement
there is one or two warthog moving
through day two just to the left of
those Impala and actually moving through
three of them see also quite clever
I'm staying close to the Impala polanco
water will be alerted that is predator
around
hearing some Franklin's calling i'm also
gonna listen out for any alarm calls any
sign of had an i and parlor alarm call
or anything like that maybe a kudu bark
but interesting behavior this is what i
wanted to show you it's amazing how when
these animals know these conditions they
need to stay close together they need to
be very very aware wonderful to see
those tails all swishing around getting
fliers off of them number of little
flies at the moment bush is very green
and especially after all the rain that
we had all very very active now this is
exactly the spot we had those wild dogs
yesterday last night these wild dogs
came and they lay down here exactly
withers impala it's amazing how one day
you can have a predator in the next day
prey in exactly the same position wonder
where those dogs went I think I ran
north I think general consensus was that
they ran north across our boundary into
buffers look and I think even all the
way up into Mannie Leyte which is not
that far from yours and crow flies
so Scarlett you you actually asked that
just what I was explaining about the
tails and you you're right it is it is
because of the flies
I mean you saw I'm not sure if you quote
this morning's Safari but we were on
bush walk the amount of flies net to
around us while we were walking it was
quite unpleasant so I know what does
Apollo going through right since shall
we continue let's see what else these
clearings have in store for us gonna hit
a little bit further down
it's funny our animals all take a bit of
shelter in weather like us it's not very
pleasant to be out they know it they
choose to hide rather than move around
too much okay let's head back over to
Tristan I wonder where he is now I'm not
sure I'm down on Weaver's nice barn we
picked up the checks for this mail line
during sort of southwards towards
Weaver's nest and now hitting South in
this direction so I just want to
double-check that there's no male line
lying somewhere here and it might be
that same one that's maybe a tree house
damn on little Gauri cuz that's not too
far what you can see is big dark ominous
clouds that are being blown in at a rate
of knots at the moment they don't look
ominous from a point of view that they
look like a lot of water but they look
like they're bringing a massive cold
front and the air temperature is
dropping by the sick and it's starting
to get quite chilly Archer quite quickly
now off on my left-hand side there is a
big bird sitting in a tree so it looks
like a pale form Wahlberg's
yes pale form Wahlberg's so probably the
one that mace is close to twin dams and
is being absolutely blown about all over
the place you can see how it's kind of
leaning into the wind a little bit so
normally the walberg sits a lot more
upright than that but this one is having
to sit quite horizontal and kind of duck
its head a little bit to try and just
balance itself and see how much the tail
is actually moving up and down in order
to keep that bird balanced while it's
sitting on top of their tree it's
getting blown about all over the place
and feathers are being a bit windswept
and this cold wind that's coming in I
think is a situation that's going to
need to a lot of birds of prey being
down on the trees this afternoon
there's no thermals to be written and in
wind like this they aren't really going
to be effective in hunting zone and then
we're gonna find a lot of our birds of
prey sitting on top of trees and taking
it easy now what I want to do is just
try and check in these male line tracks
see where they go and see what they got
up to last night
Dail burrowing birds of Jummah other
than all of the birds in FC that burrow
into the choucas and all kinds of other
blankets when it gets cold no there's no
real burrowing individuals that go
underground and spend a lot of time and
the ground and then come out so all of
our birds pretty much all either tree
nesters or there are individuals that
will miss on the ground but not
underground so they don't actually go
into it now there's some disturbance on
the road I just can't see nicely the
light is so soft and there's so much
wind that a lot of these tracks end up
looking quite windswept so I'm just
trying to see what's going on yes
there's the male line tracks he's here
but there's no blood on this particular
track at all that I can see I'll try and
just move a little bit so VM can get it
on camera but you can see what I'm
talking about hard difficult tracking
becomes in soft lights now a VM let me
get out for you so I can show you
exactly the track that I'm talking about
in fact I've even lost it a little bit
but no there it is I can see it now so
here we go this is the track now must
try not to get round it so there it is
there now you've got the toes at the
front yeah like that and then here is
the back pad on that area now that is
one track for this male line and he's
going up the road and walk down the road
so I think it must be the same
individual that we had well that is
under little Gary but let's just
double-check on the fire break maybe
it's one of the Birmingham's it was
tracking this male down it's interesting
to have a little look but tracks are
really tough to see they're not easy at
all it almost just looks like a plain
white surface at the moment so we'll try
and kind of follow these and and see
what we get but I think these might have
crossed south into little Gary already
so Samar the reason we have less big
male lions than lionesses is because if
you had as many big male lions as you
had lionesses on safari in another
situation where they'd be just complete
chaos all the time the amount of females
that would be around there'd be so much
fighting for those females and to be
able to mate with them then inevitably
males get killed and so that's why
there's less of them is that the
competition over females is so much more
as opposed to females fighting over
females doesn't really happen you know
you don't have a situation we have
females fight with each other and nests
it's two different prides in which case
they normally come together fight a
little bit and break apart whereas male
lions will actively chase each other
will actively try and kill one another
in order to bring those females back in
or to be able to take over and dominate
as well as they'll then go in and kill
young male Cubs and they'll chase some
adult males away and so that's why you
only tend to see a lot more lionesses
than you do
male lines also lionesses can move
around in a smaller section than what
big male lions can big male lions will
try and expand as far as they can and
have big territories where as a lioness
typically will try and have a much
smaller area and be encompassed by a
male that has multiple sort of females
in his territory so that's why you see
less of them good while we carry on and
see where these line tracks go that
sends you back across to Byron who's got
something that lions hunt every so often
we do indeed so again lots of antelope
aren't in the clearings now there must
be one two three four five six seven
eight nine at least nine no 10 kudu that
I can see in this area all standing very
close together see how they're all
facing different different directions
really interesting behavior and all to
do with the weather and almost change
their normal behavior depending on on
the weather and those females will be
very careful and alert to protect those
young cut and calves
these animals are looking that little
1/1 if some flies were biting it I'm
just gonna move forward slowly just to
get a better view of those cookie see
but they're all standing very close
together and I usually usually I mean
you've seen kudu they tend to move
around Oh
Justin's medicine found a find a
chameleon let's gather look quick I'm
the winner
whoa we had a bet who could find the
first chameleon and well valdi is
actually the winner he spotted the
chameleon before me so thought let me
try and go forward a little bit and see
if we can get it a little bit better
than the angle that we've got now what a
communion is doing walking around in
weather like this I'm not quite sure
where did it go of him it was right here
somewhere so I'm gonna try and just get
off and look and hear it he is right at
him so it's coming out from there it
goes
so hello little one how cool is that
color on that chameleon it's got the
most epic coloration because it's kind
of probably out on the road I was trying
to just show itself to this big vehicle
that was coming down so it's got these
Browns and whites and electric greens
and it is really a very pretty female by
the looks of things it looks like a big
female and actually looks as though she
might be carrying eggs look us swollen
her tummy is you see how a bulge that
tummy is at the moment and she's not
flaring out to make herself big and
puffy because you can't see the orange
throats so I think she might have little
eggs inside there that she maybe might
be wanting to lay but how cool is this
little chameleon is the best thing now I
know you I get very excited about this
but we haven't seen many comedians you
see look at how deep her body is at the
moment
I wonder if maybe there is some little
ones inside there interesting but the
coloration of this particular chameleon
is absolutely phenomenal it is really
super bright and the kind of camouflage
then it's trying to show is very
where are you off to you must be careful
now a comedian out in the open like this
is in a lot of danger there's a number
of birds archaea that go after comedians
so particularly things like the grey
headed bush Shrike they are very
dangerous to comedians they come out and
they'll grab him and then a number of
different snakes - so Boomslang vine
snake numbers cobras they'll all go
after a chameleon look it's just peering
at us through the grass you see that
they are the coolest things and they've
got these incredible eyes where they are
able to manipulate each eye individually
or from the other one now Jeff you say
that's a first for you to see well Jeff
I hope you're enjoying it because they
are super cool little creatures and like
I say not something we get to see every
day so that's very cool and I didn't
expect to see a chameleon at all in
conditions like this this is not really
chameleon whether we find them out in
warm evenings but that was super cool so
I'm glad we got to see it and so while
we carry on and see what else we can
find or what other mysteries they are in
the bush that scene you bet across to
buy it and yes could you well that's
awesome haven't seen a chameleon in a
long time
I'm hoping to spot them at night but we
haven't seen one so it's the first one
we've seen for ages see they're hiding
in the long grass I think I'll watch
these oxpeckers and the kudu cleaning
all the ticks off those years and get
right in there
as I was saying nice to see all these
and these coulda together I haven't seen
a group this size for quite some time
but all very very cautious in the wind
I wonder what that could ring on there
looked a little little hard
you see it's swallowed whatever it was
in it at times because these could whose
have these really long necks you can see
when they regurgitate food again being
ruminants you can see that little food
ball come back up and then they start
chewing so let's let's actually see if
as female does it get knit do you see
that exactly what I was speaking about
yeah wonderful so she just regurgitate
to that food again now she reaches it
that's why the the most there or
actually all the Antelope do it they're
obviously ruminants very efficient
digestive system regurgitate what they
fed on it's mixed with them some enzymes
and and stomach juices and then that
helps digest it even further and then
eventually they'll swallow it again and
it's broken and happen and again it was
another one another one for that chicas
full of food
mark I'm not sure I would I would guess
at times the oxpeckers don't actually
get the entire tick off the animal and
maybe leave their head behind for those
of you don't know when you pull a tick
off you've got to be very careful to get
the the head of the tick out because
often that head
digs into your skin and and will sit
there and when you pull the ticket
brakes off and that can cause a bit of
an infection
now with the oxpeckers I mean they comb
so finely across the skin of these
animals that I'm sure they usually get
the whole tick but at times I think it's
inevitable that the head breaks off on
the animal we saw a lot of ticks this
morning on Bush walk I haven't got itchy
yet but I'm waiting because a lot of
pepper ticks around at the moment - not
very pleasant
no I'm just listening to something I can
hear you see all those could be watching
actually if we just zoom out a little
bit since I sorry
you see those could very focus I can't
you know what is the guinea fowl alarm
calling now let's see if I can maybe get
through there it sounds like it's quite
fine the block but guinea fowl
definitely alarm calling at something
all these could've turned it and face
that way immediately I wonder if there
is a gap to get through here look at all
these kudu together
it's amazing one Impala he's he's clever
staying close to the kudu can you follow
very unhappy I'm going to go look in
there quickly let's go across to Elly
and fun at wishes I'm going to try get
in there and see if we can find what
these guinea fowl are upset about it
seems like Byron is normally lucky when
guinea fowls are alarming around him so
I'm hoping that there will be something
in that particular area we are on our
way to chatauqua we've bumped into a
herd of elephants so it's always
wonderful to spend some time with them
now the ones that we're looking at are a
little further away from where we are
but I just want to stand still because
there are some on the bushes very close
to us and they might come out onto the
road in the next few minutes or so
so I think it'll be worth it if we're
patient and then they'll just might pop
out in here now updates front in Ghana
it seems that he's moved and he's no
longer where we left him this morning so
I think we're still gonna try and get
down onto that area see if we can
perhaps figure out where he's gone and
if not then we'll just go around
Chittoor maybe we'll get lucky now this
is the particular elephant that we were
talking about that's very close to the
road but I think she's just taking she
him we'll see now taking its time coming
into the road there's a little one
hello almost there difference are also
they alert in the one they don't
particularly like it and I would imagine
for them it's even more annoying because
with such big ears
they eat if the wind is probably Oh
bother more than anything else are you
do I need to move the car I think maybe
I am going to move the car slightly so
that we get a bit of a view because it
seems like elephants always act that
they like they've got all the time in
the world and well pretty sure that they
do so it's just I think that if we go
like this perhaps we'll be able to get a
view of them without getting the poles
of a roof and the way how's that for you
fern
does that work alright so it's the
mother and the most recent of spring and
it seems like there's one at the back as
well so the last two offsprings that
she's had are you guys eating the grass
yes they're eating the grass at the
bottom of the tree I thought perhaps
they were interested oh I don't know if
you can hear that but there was a lot of
rumbling
Jessica officially there are only two
elephant species there's the African
elephant and the Asian elephant but
there's a lot of debate going on in the
scientific and conservationist
communities because there's another
species or subspecies of elephant as
they want to consider it now which is
the forest elephant very similar to this
particular elephant that we're looking
at very similar to the African elephants
they do live in the forest in Africa
they're just slightly smaller now
because they are completely separated
from the normal elephants that we see
over the savanna elephant that we see a
lot of people want to classify them as a
completely different species because if
they're classified as a completely
different species because there are so
few of them then automatically they were
warned a higher conservation protection
so there's a bit of debate in theory
though we only get this beautiful one
that we're looking at and then the Asian
one and the Asian ones are slightly
different from the African one the Asian
ones are a little bit more docile and
smaller years and more pigmentation
around their face now we're going from
giants to tiny ones and it seems like
Justin has got one of the smaller
creatures of the bush I do indeed have
one of the cutest creatures which is now
obviously disappeared because well this
is what happens whenever you want to
show a creature off it disappears but
there's a special tail sticking inside
there so that is a little tree squirrel
that is kind of hidden inside of that
area now there's another squirrel that's
alarm calling just in front that I want
to go and investigate quickly it's I
suppose weather that you could have
things moving around we've just seen a
chameleon obviously moved so maybe a
snake could be around but I just want to
double check that's why there's a bird
of prey right yeah so is it a battle-ax
eagle yes it is a veterinary go okay
okay okay
you don't have to worry it's a battery a
eagle it's just it's not going to hunt
you
so the squirrel is going crazy because
it's seen a bird of prey but the reason
why is because it just sees that shape
and it things to itself probably this is
drama you hear I think as the eagle
flying off so this squirrel is probably
petrified that anything with wings is
going to be some sort of death that's
going to come towards it so that's why
it makes all that noise now that it's
flown away all is quiet okay we've got
your point thank you for showing us that
that's not every day you get to hear
them
[Music]
[Music]
that's what we always look for when we
say schools our alarm calling that's the
sound that we're actually talking about
and it's a very cool Sun now I'm sure
there's different frequencies pitches
and tones depending on whether it's a
bird or a leopard or snake but honestly
I don't know what the difference is
between them I find with lipids they far
more insistent in what kind of
repetitive and a lot quicker and a lot
higher but this is I mean it's difficult
to say what they actually looking at so
you always have to try and investigate
it and that's why we always follow up on
alarm courses you never know what you're
gonna get from a squirrel anyway we're
going to send you back across to those
big animals that Ellie is still with and
hopefully they will come out and have a
really nice view of them well they
haven't now it seems like they're going
again now unfortunately they have
crossed into a property that I cannot
follow them but at least for now we've
got a nice view of them heading into the
bush and you can see the branches are
moving a little bit so I think that's
why they're not all that happy now it
sounded like there were some more
elephants behind us so I'm just gonna go
and explore perhaps we can see a few
more elephants coming all the way from
chitra Dam and then we'll just delay or
search for some gana a little bit maybe
he's actually at the dam himself I
wouldn't I wouldn't put it past him to
go back to that spot but there are a few
spaces where I want to go check for him
but if there are more elephants down
down at the dam that would be very nice
to go and view them if they're drinking
now I'm hoping they'll be there lots of
wood
now it was funny because when we were
sitting with those elephants earlier on
I don't know if you guys could hear the
1p mo grumbling and she was quite
aggressive about it in the little ones
instead of coming onto the road where
she did it's almost like they had to
walk in the bush and then cross where
the rest of the herd had crossed further
ahead it's almost like she said no you
don't this is not the road for you to
cross you need to do it further away and
then they went all the way and around
cliff would have been just fine for them
been just fine for them to walk around
it but clearly there was something that
was unsettling her and she just felt
that her youngsters had to do the route
that the other ones had done now let's
see hopefully there will be some
elephants at the end of the road or at
the end of the rainbow if we can find
either the rainbow or the not too sure
perhaps they were calling from far away
because with this wind I wouldn't be
surprised that noises that are being
carried a little bit further if we are
on the right end of the wind now I
doesn't see him for now that there are
any elephants down at the dam
or maybe they are controversy from here
but we're gonna approach and go down
there anyway see what's lurking but -
today on this afternoon perhaps some
bigger things perhaps some smaller
things and we'll see what birds are
braving the weather
infinity gave him some reserves do you
have fences in between them the reserve
that we're in now is part of the greater
Kruger National Park which means that
this reserve has got no fences to the
eastern side with Kruger National Park
now there is a fence on the western side
because that's the limit of the natural
or the protected area and the idea for
that fence is to prevent animals from
going into the local communities but
it's just the most western boundary and
we are or the sabi sand is that the
southern almost the southern part
central part of the Kruger National Park
and then there's another massive reserve
more towards the north which is a timber
of articular Sierra which also form part
of the greater Kruger National Park and
there is a boundary in between the the
main roads and again the human
settlements but there are no fences in
between all the different smaller
reserves that make up each one of these
individual reserves now I think we have
found all of the impala got excited
because there's a tiny tiny baby water
book right here is that fine okay sorry
I'm still learning my way I'm gonna get
my head out of the way because there's a
tiny tiny baby water bug it seems like
today is the day of the little things
you are just the smallest water bug I've
seen it's so incredibly cute this is a
brand new one I haven't seen this one
before and well this morning was spent a
lot of time with a lot of water buck
that we're around here with some
youngsters so what I think has been
happening is this one has been hiding in
the long grass the mother has probably
not brought it down here before and now
it's a little bit older than this is why
she's finally brought it on to this area
surprise there aren't any other water
bucket just the mail but maybe they've
gone somewhere foraging or they're
somewhere at the under other end of the
open area whoo you can see it's not it
doesn't have its great color just yet
it's still of a tawny color almost looks
like a little Impala yeah Chris is
saying it looks so fuzzy all the way
from NC and I agree with you I feel like
I want a baby water buck as a pet it
would be the best thing although it
would probably kill Justin kids baby
water bugs carry a lot of ticks or just
water bucking yet in general but that is
the sweetest face look at that and just
in terms of heights I would say that's
what 45 centimeters tall Fergus do you
agree with that maybe a little bit more
50 yeah I think about 50 so it'd be a
small probably the size of a medium -
yeah medium-sized dog I would say oh so
cute and it's already got its white ring
around its rump a tiny little target
maybe that's what we should call him we
should call him target just because this
is a little one very cute
Jenny a mini target but you say I agree
with you that's the way should call it
mini target
it's very pretty very very pretty oh I
wish there were more because then we
would see what they get off to and how
they play now you see they're all
surrounded by Impala and like I said
earlier I think we have found all of the
Impala in the service and they're
probably in this massive open area now I
can't go both ways sometimes with Impala
they'll come into this areas because
they can see far away and they are very
protected over here because there is no
predator that's gonna be able to
approach them without them noticing but
part of the issues also that because
there is a lot of wind the temperature
starts dropping so they're gonna start
getting cold so they might have to then
retreat back into an area that's a
little bit more sheltered just to be
able to maintain certain body heat
although they all seem to be eating the
grass so I'm sure that's gonna help them
metabolize and just keep a certain
temperature you can hear the wind is
howling
that is that is the cutest little baby
water book and all of the baby impala
they seem to have grown fairly fast only
seen a few every now and again that have
that that small baby look to them stole
most of them seem that they've gone on
to the the so bad old face oh so pretty
hi guys all of you eating
Ginty impeller gestation period is about
six months normally they mates run about
in May and then they give birth
somewhere around October November it
depends on when they made if it's a
little bit later than May their egos
running then it'll all change but it's
about six seven months period depending
on the condition sometimes if the
conditions are not good and they're
going through away or we're going
through a very dry winter then it might
just take the features a little bit
longer to develop so might the gestation
period might be prolonged for a few
weeks you almost look like a little
Impala where's your mom
there's an Impala going in between mom
and the little one I think there's a
little bit of panic mode yep
running the wrong way you're hiding
amongst all of the Impala you can almost
pass for an Impala yourself
all right seems like someone's full of
energy now it's realized that it can
chase all of the Impala it's almost like
little kids when you take them to the
park and they start running around
chasing all the birds I almost feel like
that's what this little one is doing
it's realize that it can chase everyone
away very cute
now you're just being brave aren't you
terrifying everyone all right do it
again one two three go
or maybe not
having a standard with an Impala it's
funny how his ears and how alert he
already or it already is just looking
around and when it was a little bit
scared I just stood still ears flapping
on around and then started running and
it's looking very healthy as well I
think it's fun has been able to feed
well so clearly she's producing very
nutritious milk for this little one to
be looking in such good condition very
beautiful coats as well you're a brand
new one only a few weeks old mini target
that is very cute it's smaller than an
Impala oh that's not gonna be the case
for longer if you manage to make it to
adulthood you'll be quite big definitely
bigger than an Impala it's fascinating
that the color is so similar because as
they grow older then it's gonna start
losing that coloration and it's gonna
become great just like its mom was I
don't know if its legs are starting to
get that color already if it's perhaps
been in the mud or in wet soil and
that's why it's looking that color now
the male is very interested in this
female he's picking up a lot of smells
that she's putting down every time she
stopped to urinate he's been smelling
her and I don't think it's for mating
purposes p.m. her house because she's
had a little one he's just trying to
decipher what it is that's going on but
I don't think she is well clearly she's
just had this young one so she's not
know she won't be ready to mate until
this one is weaned and sort of almost
ready to settle into adulthood very
beautiful rumps
cool breeze and pollen water bugs can
eat the same plants water bug tend to be
a little bit picky about the grass that
they eat so it's it's a lot of study
suggests that they prefer grass that's
very high in protein and they've got to
be around water a lot to just be able
for the or they've got to drink a lot of
water because of the type of grass that
they eat so they're often found around
this area's very close to water now and
pile out there they're very adaptable
creatures so they can feed on on many
different plants and though they're
considered
mixed feeders they won't only eat the
grass but they will also eat the leaves
of the trees and fruits here and there
so I think it's a case of the Impala can
eat what the water bugs eat but just the
water bug don't really eat what the
Impala can eat if that makes sense I
know it sounds like a riddle but I
promise you it makes a lot of sense this
is nice
seems like chitra Dam has been nice and
sheltered we're gonna carry on exploring
see who else we can find on here perhaps
another baby but while we do that let's
head back to byron who's rejoin the
lions I have I haven't we have some
heads up at the moment
so I'd followed up on those guinea fowl
alarm call there was a predator around
just not one with rosettes
it was a Warburg's eagle so those guinea
fowl obviously would be nervous of the
Warburg's the Warburg's do to catch and
hunt birds and that's what it was and as
you got to the Warburg's flew off but
but it just shows you those guinea fowl
there alarm calls when that a whole
group of them alarm call like that
there's definitely something there it
could be a bird of prey and it could be
a snake it could also be a leopard so
that's why we went to go and have a look
but it was a Warburg's eagle anyway I'm
hoping that now we've come back the
temperatures dropped quite a bit it
feels quite chilly at the moment so I'm
hoping these Lions decide to get a bit
active and move around
but I'm not sure Joan so no the Lions
don't purr and I don't think lions are
able to purr the only big cat that can
purr and that purring sound that we
would associate with cats the only big
cat that can do it is as a cheetah
cheetah duper but Lions do not lines do
not their voice box is slightly
different and I don't think they have
the ability tipper to metal that
cartilage and bone in the throat that
allows him to raw same of lipids
leopards also do not and he's got a
reptile heading into the water
we do and it's gotten back into the
water
No Oh almost there almost there sorry
Frank that was my bad who we were trying
to get a view of the crocodile heading
back into the water because just as we
saw it it's almost turned around and
started heading back and I think it's
cutting a little bit too cold for Vlad
as well it's decided to go probably
where it's warmer rather than stay out
here in the cold breeze that's starting
to come now we can still see its tail in
its head
he's definitely standing still and I
wonder if it's perhaps there's a hippo
not too far from him now such a long
tail come on do it again all you have to
do now is get out and then come back in
and then we'll be very happy about it
it's amazing this morning we came here
and we couldn't find traces of em or at
least I couldn't find it but I wouldn't
be surprised if he was just on the back
part of the island because we didn't
check here this morning mmm look at
those teeth so white and clean looks
quite menacing when the teeth are
exposed like that who wouldn't really
try and make my way towards any sort of
crocodile and it's funny because where I
come from we have also I'm originally
from South America and there we have so
many different species of crocodiles and
Caymans and they're not as grumpy as a
Nile crocodiles I should say they're
very the Nile crocodiles have a
reputation of being a lot more ferocious
and aggressive and perhaps some of the
ones that we get where I'm from and in
those areas even you can have a dam like
this and get in the water with them and
they will pretty much not do anything to
you a nice word you know if it's a
caiman if it's a bigger species they
might have a bit of an issue but you can
swim very close to them and they want to
attack them whereas here in South Africa
I would never ever dreamed of coming
close to any sort of water body where
there are hippos or crocodiles involved
no that is a rock not a hippo yeah I
thought it was worth checking but no
sorry that was all me now let's see who
else is around here lots of hippos I
don't seem to be all that playful today
hello bush buck are you guys doing today
baby you water buck well they could have
been there they're about the right color
now I think the rest of the water bug
that we saw this morning are actually on
the other side of the of the dam so
we've got the water buck on the ride
with the ring around it's from the bush
buck the ones on the left and then the
birds on the left those are the
blacksmith brothers and then what is the
other one could really tell what it is
I think it's just out of reach for my
binoculars but it looks like if like a
white face whistling duck
perhaps so my favorite Ducks are around
now um where should we go I think we're
gonna see May we can find the Gosling's
again the the Egyptian geese Gosling's
but while we do that let's head back to
byron and I hope that it's not as windy
there as it is here yeah but definitely
I don't think it's as windy as it is
there I know what took to a dam is like
got some yawn so there's a bit of
activity stretching cleaning grooming
one another so we might be lucky and
these lines might decide to get up I do
however hope that they walk this way
I'll tell you why it's because if they
go away from us that bushes so thick we
won't be able to follow them through
there I can tell you that now and would
be extremely difficult we'll have to
drive around and wait on the other side
and hopefully they come through
I was laughing at Ellie saying she'd
love to have her was a little water back
you're a young water back but Justin
would get upset for the tics now I would
imagine couple goals in the bush finding
a pet that you birth
okay so comfortable
[Laughter]
that's very difficult to have pizza not
a good idea
I was just thinking about chit chat with
Dan and I haven't been there yet on this
I've driven past but I haven't spent
time there it's maybe tomorrow I'm going
to ask if I may be allowed to go to
Chitra have a look at this one in the
lift yeah cool breeze I'm the Lions you
know what to be honest I don't know how
they decide it's time to go it's just
when they feel comfortable and they feel
like they've rested enough and they feel
like it's cool enough that they don't
exert too much energy they know they'll
get up and move I just want to try and
maneuver off to the side yeah Christina
hold on a second
try get a view of these playful lines
but while I do that I'm Ellie seems to
have found those Gosling's at Chitra
damn it's gonna look
sorry Byron we were with the Gosling's
but then something else caught our eye
and it's this neeyala that are on the
other side this they were doing their
sideways display and it's normally a way
for them to resolve any sort of issue
when it comes to hierarchy especially if
there are females that are ready to mate
that are involved in the process now it
seems like the wind is bothering a lot
of the animals as they stand still and
carry on listening and of course now
they've stopped doing their display as
they were a few minutes ago I'm hoping
they're gonna go back to it because it's
very interesting I think I can hear some
guinea fowl alarming in the distance but
it's very hard to tell with the wind now
there we go you see that Daniel are
roughly raising their head their hair
they're called Pilar erection and
although I think the wind is not really
helping them all that much what they do
is they tend to approach one another
sideways and I think this is not as
aggressive as it should have been and
perhaps the wind that's actually
confusing me but when they do raise
their head like that what they do is
they'll go and stand next to one another
to try and make themselves look bigger
than what they really are and the whole
idea of raising their heads and doing
this display is almost like when the
elephants go and they open their ears
and raise their heads to make themselves
appear bigger than what they really are
to try and intimidate the opponent and
not having to get into a fight so that
way everybody knows who's who and you
don't really have to fight for it it's
already decided just by looking at each
other now there's random female in the
middle so I wonder if she's perhaps the
reason for all of this
or all of this some males being around
because
neeyala yes it can be sometimes on in
the close proximity but these are a lot
of males one two three four five six
males in the same area then there's
definitely someone that's perhaps ready
to may that's attracted all these males
and that's why they're all here you see
they're all keeping their distance and
it's funny because they're they've just
left this MIMO in the middle she could
be the one that's potentially you ready
to mate or if not there are quite a few
other females around so I wouldn't be
surprised if this one just sort of
happened to catch herself in the middle
of all of them very beautiful no I think
let's go back to you the Gosling's I
think maybe they're just gonna have to
you start moving now I apologize for the
wind and maybe if the sound is coming a
little bit funny we've got four
Gosling's though I'm happy to report it
doesn't seem like we've lost any of them
in the last few days which is always a
success probably means that husana
hasn't been around here trying to eat
any one of them they're all looking good
and they're looking bigger and still
they've got that beautiful killer well
look to the back of them now these were
the ones that we were looking at earlier
on when byron link to us and they are
all very fluffy and I think they're also
lying they close to each other because
they're probably very cold yeah it's
almost like they were standing on top of
one another very cold little things so
to try and keep warm that's often what
they do a lot of the birds they just
require on body heat or the warmth that
it's irradiated by each one of them to
keep warm we've got the two little ones
that have gone into the water perhaps
the braver ones and then the other two
that seem to be the bigger ones at the
back did you just fall while scratching
your wing I think that's exactly what
happened yeah I don't think this would
be the pet that I would want though not
I feel like I'm not in it to have
now all the apana are running on the
damn wall and I don't know if it's just
because of the wind or if it's because
there's something else that's running
behind them earlier on the guinea fowl
alarming but it could have just been
anything else it could be nothing it
could be just the wind spooking them but
they're all running back into the open
area follow some antelope can't swim the
water buck are very good at it that's
part of the reason why they're called
water buck name they're always found
close to the water but the impala can
also swim if especially if wild dogs are
behind them I've seen them often that's
that I've seen them often go into the
middle of the dam and try to get out of
the reach of the water of the wild dogs
because the wall dogs will not get them
in the water so different different
antelopes are more adapted to more
aquatic environment the fuku for example
or the leche in Botswana are more
adapted to this type of life so that you
can over you can see them more often
than not in the water but just to go in
the water for a swim and to have fun
no the water's more a means to an end
you are so cute but you guys are on the
wrong side of the open area everybody's
on the other side so that's perhaps
where you should go so that you're
protected with the rest of your group
one drifting ganas not perhaps somewhere
around here and that's why they're all
getting so spooked and running around so
cute you've got a run a little bit
faster to keep up with your mom now the
open air is a very good place for them
to be as I said earlier they can see
anything coming from quite a distance
but I think that in this particular time
I don't think there's anything specific
that's lurking in the darkness or in
between the bushes I think it's just
they can't hear very well probably a lot
of smells are being taken away and
they're just have to be a little bit
more an edge just to make sure that they
don't get caught unaware and then
something pounces on them because
obviously that would be or probably
would be the end of it I think maybe
we're gonna go and explore in the
direction where the waterbug are facing
let's see let's see maybe some of the if
ting ganas around there if there are any
tracks for him while we reposition and
go all the way there let's head back to
byron as it seems like the liars are
starting to wake up
well this has been a bit of movement and
these lines still cleaning one another
but heads are up
so for more movement than we thought
when we found them earlier on drive but
it's so you know what the best way to
describe the weather is it is a bit
miserable at the moment and there's no
other way to describe it it's wonderful
and cool which I'm really enjoying the
cool weather from the heat that we had
yesterday and but but the wind and that
does make it a bit miserable and I think
this is hot chocolate and Safari live
weather maybe maybe I'm going to head
back to camp and then I'll watch Tristan
and Ellie for the rest of the drive all
I have some hot chocolate
what do you think sensor
Big Boss Man
Tristan apparently gave curse the BDI
and gave curse the beady eye and shook
his head so that's a no-no what if
Justin's going to give me a disciplinary
after this a little bit of playfulness
on the left since a look no see these
young lines soon as one gets bitten in
there's no more playfulness young lions
always really great to watch because
they do get very playful and they did
that stretching and jump on one another
especially when the pride starts to move
and they get quite active
so quite there are a few birds calling
in the distance cape turtle Dave sounded
like perhaps a scrub Robin so there are
a few birds calling that seemed too many
of them okay holding on tightly in this
wind
probably well-hidden I had some arrow
mark babblers earlier too so the birds
are out
I did see that little cab I am but it
was it's hidden from us at the moment
it's lying a little bit further to the
left with another lioness through
basically through that tree through the
back there that's also I don't think
you'll see it but it's in there
somewhere but don't worry about it since
I will wait and see if or when they
start to move it hopefully get to see
them alright well it's that time where
we need to go back to Tristan and find
out what he's actually been doing and
where he is
Oh Byron I've been sitting in if see
having a hot chocolate I thought you
that's what we were going to do you told
me you're gonna come and join me but you
never arrived so I've done that's now
I'm just getting back arts again just to
go and see what's going one what I want
to show you guys I just had a thought
quickly it's going to take me a little
bit of time to get there you will see me
reversing because I want to go and show
you something very cool but we've been
in the meantime while we kind of get
there I'll tell you what I've been up to
really ecause I haven't been NFC having
hot chocolate even though it sounds like
a fantastic idea Byron I've been driving
around looking for Tanja and so far
absolutely no sign no sign of really
anything actually no birds no sort of
insects just wind that's all we've had
so far
and it's been pretty miserable at the
moment you know I believe there's lots
of rain to the south of us around
Johannesburg area so I wonder if maybe
that's going to come up this way at some
point right you might be wondering why
am i driving here what is you what am i
up to well I'll show you fairly shortly
just give me two seconds to get in here
quickly and so that I can show you
exactly what I mean now there we go
Looby is that's close enough
so I wanted to show you guys what
happens when male lions vs leopards
climb trees and how different it looks
when a male lion goes on to a tree now
normally what we'll find is when a
leopard goes on to a tree you'll find
little core marks like these so if you
have a look with my finger is bill deep
there's little slices like this and this
is probably from where Tandy dug in and
she took a carcass up a tree we know
that then tenure came along and he went
up this tree and you can see the
difference between his clothes look at
how deep that is etched into the wood
it's gone right and I can almost put my
pretty much my finger inside there and
so that's his cause and it gives you an
idea of also just how wide his claws are
here's the other one over here so it
would be something along that's sort of
lines
that's how wide his poor would have been
as he tried to grab and go up and you
can actually see them all the way up as
he fought his way trying to get through
big deep gouges into this military now
it's something that's you don't see very
often and if you came across here
somebody would probably think that
Wolverine had been around but it's not
Wolverine from the x-men this is a
tenure from the Birmingham male
coalition that went all the way out
there to go and Fitch those two
different kills that Tammy had in this
tree over a month ago so just pretty
insane to kind of see the depth and the
size of these pores when they on the
tree in you knew see lipids kind of
markings and they're always quite small
and you can see it quite clearly but
just to see the width in these is just
absolutely phenomenal it's an amazing
thing I can show you just with my hand
these are the cool marks over here and
that's just the size of my hand in
comparison so his pores I'm bigger than
my hand basically which is pretty insane
and you can actually see where he
slipped here and his claws kind of came
down and he moved and he was battled his
way up into the tree as we know he
almost fell a few times so I thought it
would be just a cool thing we were right
share we might as well have gone into it
and had a little look and showing you
all what it looks like when Lions climb
marula trees the poem really suffers a
little bit but the lion himself did
quite well I think tenure did a sterling
efforts to get up into that tree to see
that rights now I'm gonna try and find
an animal of sorts and maybe even the
very lipid isthat had the kill in the
tree and while I do that I believe Ali
has spotted something so it's quickly go
across to her we have spotted a good old
friend Tristan this is indeed 10 Ghana
now he is not too far away from cheated
on funny enough and I think he's being
very clever there are so many Impala
around here this is probably the best
spot for him to start hunting this
afternoon now I wouldn't be surprised if
he's done this on purpose he's walked a
certain distance from where he was he
was probably the top part of the meloni
near the cheetah property now he's gone
pretty much towards the end so oh no I
would say maybe about 1k 2k is at max
but he's now found another comfortable
bush where to sleep in and it is very
cold so I'm sure he's chosen that spot
for shelter and as the Sun starts to go
down or as
gets darker because it's already quite
dark he might try and head in the
direction of all the Impala and the
water back and Egyptian geese and all
the different creatures that are at the
moment seeking shelter in the open area
very clever of you ting honor you know
exactly where to go and he's probably
still a little bit weak it's probably
the reason why he's been hanging around
a certain area and hasn't covered much
of his territory I'm sure he's just
waiting to you gain forest again or
recuperate a little bit from his illness
so that he can then try and start moving
around he seems to be under man and I
mean he stomach seems to be a little bit
fuller than the last time I saw him
which was a few days ago he seems to be
doing a little bit better he's still a
bit on the skinny side but it seems he's
on the man which I'm very excited about
his I've come to really enjoy taganas
company all the way from last minute
leopard to you being the boy that
features in the most so I'm hoping that
he's going to do well tonight they're
the stars are almost aligning for him
with big storm approaching lots of wind
so he all he has to do is just be very
careful of how he approaches all the
different creatures around and he might
get lucky
infinity gaming you're wondering how we
can identify which Leopard it is well
normally there are a few ways of trying
to identify the leopards you can look at
their spot whisker pattern so the spots
on top or whether they're just on top of
their whiskers and that they're
different for every leopard so they'll
have maybe four on one side five on the
other side and if you can see the whole
face and you can just get an idea of the
side profile now in this particular case
we know that it's him because it's not
too far from where we saw him in the
morning
but also we saw him get up and then move
around and then go back into the bushes
so the more we tend to spend time with
some of the leopards the easier it
becomes to identify some of them you can
almost tell straight away and slide ok I
think it's this one and if there's any
doubt then you can always use their spot
pattern to be 100% sure which individual
you're looking at in this particular
case I think more than by looking at
whiskers or anything else we've gone by
location where he was a morning where he
is now and when he got up he's got this
this look he's got a face so it's easy
to recognize if you I don't know how to
explain it but if you imagine a lot of
people you won't be able to tell their
faces apart at first if they all look
roughly the same but the more you look
at them the easier you it becomes for
you to start memorizing their features
hey boy I'm looking a little bit tired
aren't you
well he's got a good spot underneath
this Bush willow seems like a bush Widow
to me and he's lying and fools in a very
leopard spreaded way like you know he's
butter on a toast or something that's
the way he's spread and it would be very
hard to see him coming from the other
way we just wanted we came unto this
edge because we just wanted to check
there was a possibility of him moving
not too far and we just got lucky in the
fat man he was here which is Vega and
because we're very happy cuz now we can
see him and enjoy him for the afternoon
which is more than what we had planned
on was I thought he might have stayed in
the area where he was in this morning
but when I heard he had moved the
possibilities of places where he could
have been were pretty endless so I think
the log has been on our side a little
bit and there's always that wonderful
gut feeling that sometimes tells you to
turn in the right direction I think
that's partly what lead fergan isle
bunch of this particular spot today I
think that was it wasn't it now he's
sleepy you can see the wind is still
howling beautiful now it seems like
Byron is so with the Lions and I'm
hoping they're a little bit more active
than the leopard
well there is a bit of movement eleena
is a bit I'm glad you got to see ting on
again so I'm assuming his in the same
place he was this morning and but you
know these lines this every now and then
one of them will stand up and move
around and then lay down and then
another one will be the same so I'm not
a lot of movement but but the heads are
they're definitely more active than the
pride we saw yesterday I'm so hold on
hold on since let me try this cookie
sorry tell you why because the the
little cab is hiding in here but there
seems to be a lot of activity from them
just through here maybe we can get a
view if I go can you get through there
let's see let's see maybe we can show
you a little bit of the activity from
yet some the sub-adult but the the
little cub is is in there just to the
left that's hiding is that it yeah
that's it very cute earlier one of these
sub-adults walked up to the cabin they
were having a bit of a standoff
Steve so there are animals that
obviously carry diseases out in the in
the wild not like mad come up at sea
maybe this youngster climbs into the
tree and this dead tree sometimes they
do do that they get a bit curious and
active and Steve so these Lions last
year they had a disease called white
muscle disease and they got that from a
food deficiency they weren't getting I
don't think they were getting enough fat
and the nutrients that they need from
their food so it causes the muscles to
stiffen up and and can cause the lines
to die but they managed to get through
it okay and then they can sometimes get
mange
so mange can occur in some of these
animals also with drafter net what else
wild dogs get canine distemper if they
sometimes pick up from we don't really
know how they pick it up at times
occasionally well the most plausible
cause is getting in contact with feral
dogs
but yeah I think what else the Buffalo
the Cape Buffalo that you have in this
area they get a bovine tuberculosis at
times but that's also from being in
contact with with local cattle and that
so that can spread quite easily but but
you know generally the animals are
healthy and those diseases can kind of
come and go or only affects them when
they get and get much older and they're
all weak then the chances are probably
higher that that disease is gonna affect
it and they're going to die from it but
generally the animals are healthy
there's a little cub playing with well
my things being picked on he or she's
been picked on at the moment
it is very peaceful sitting watching the
Lions well I'm still going to sit and
wait I think it might be worth our while
I'm hoping so but let's go back to Le
with that male leopard and see what ting
gone is up to has not moved all that
much if at all whatsoever but we're
gonna keep guard here just in case he
does decide to get off and start moving
it'll be nice to see him approach all of
this area and I'll be quite curious to
see if he is going to try the open area
and all the different prey species that
are lurking in there if he perhaps is
gonna try go somewhere else and try his
luck in an area that's a little bit more
sure sheltered where he can bump into
you perhaps something smaller like a
tiger or steam bug or perhaps a lonely
Impala that's looking for some warmth
out in the out in the bush you've had a
very deep sleep and I don't blame you in
a Sunday like today
Jessica leopards are considered mostly
solitary creatures so unless you see a
mother and a cub or perhaps young
siblings together it's very rare to see
more than one leper together so it's
very pointed details and during their
lifetime when they will actually spend
some time with some other leopards they
don't hunt together they have seen and
funny enough Judi H Woodson sent me a
video yesterday so haven't been able to
see of two young male leopards sharing a
kill when they were still old enough not
to you have to share a kill they didn't
hunt it together but there was a little
bit apparently of violence in between
the two of them but because they were
siblings and they almost forcibly shared
the kill now this particular medal that
we're seeing he seems to be quite
sociable with his offspring as well and
not so long ago we had a case where he
was allowing two of his sons that are
not directly related to one another
allowing them to to share a kill with
him this where husana and Thumba now it
doesn't happen all that often but I find
it interesting that it depends when you
talk about animals it depends of what
area you're talking about so now a lot
of the leopards have been studied in
different parts different reserves
perhaps here's where there isn't high
such as high density as there is here in
the Savi sand which is considered one of
the areas with the most leopard density
in the world so in this particular spot
perhaps because there are too many of
them they seem to be more sociable or be
more tolerant of other leopards than
perhaps leopards in other areas I'm sure
it's proves that there's a an exception
to every rule and you've got to take a
lot of factors into consideration and
every time you know do you think there's
a rule there might be someone that just
shows you that you're entirely wrong but
in general terms no leopards do not hunt
together and they do not share kill
unless it's a mother and a young
or let's in some sort of situation where
it's leopards that are somehow related
but uh that that would be as far as I
would stretch it I've never seen leather
its hunt together the same way as lions
do for example you are completely asleep
though there is your eyes open so you
are well aware that there is a lot going
on his ears are not that alert so I
think he's just trying to block the wind
out and it almost seemed when he got and
laid down on this putt that he was
trying to get underneath all that
foliage and just trying to get and
squeeze in as much as possible but I
think perhaps the branches are too low
for him to try and do that the spot
where he was in in the morning was a lot
better for that well I seem as I'd the
other cats who funny enough also have
some spots are kind of playing so let's
head over to them yeah we've got a
little bit of bit of activity here a
little cab isn't that cute
picking up little sticks
cool breeze I don't I don't think
animals experience boredom like we do
you know I do say this often I think we
need to be very very careful of of
anthropomorphizing animals too much
giving them human emotions like boredom
I mean that that I think would be very
unfair to to assume that they get bored
I don't think so animals animals do what
they need to Lions they risk during the
day that's general lion behavior I don't
think it's because of boredom or
anything even the playfulness that we
are seeing now from them waking up and
you can just see that little cabin super
tricky pollen in Reverse little hope
maybe know as I say that cab decides
it's had enough maybe it's going to go
and bother someone else
oh no no move forward now so I don't
think it's that's definite actually it's
not I don't think it's definitely not
boredom definitely not boredom wow this
one to the left was stretching and
clawing away at the bark of the tree
what is the thing that's really
interesting jumped into that tree if it
saw something you just reverse a little
bit and if it saw something go up into
their tree I don't think so
doesn't look like it I haven't seen any
movement they're gonna very quickly no I
think it's just being a boisterous
youngster
sounds like ting ganas on the move so
let's go across to Elly and see where
that male leopard is going well we
thought that he was gonna get and go but
he's just gone a few steps ahead and
he's laid down again so we can just oh
sorry not going into you here
sorry somebody's
there you go
all right there we go
yeah sorry my radio doesn't copy
everything you guys say I'm on the
eastern side just come towards the south
and then you'll see me there the bottom
side close to the lodge side so if you
come completely towards room 11 then
you'll see me there I'm on the open area
side all right so it's a little bit
tricky sometimes to try and direct
people into certain areas but because
there are obviously other vehicles and
other guests I would like to see a
leopard and perhaps this is their only
chance ever to see a leopard and we like
to sort of help them or direct them into
this particular spot now it's in Ghana
like we said earlier he walked about two
steps and then he sat down and that was
about it we did think that he maybe was
gonna try and hide in another bush and
sleep in there but perhaps he feels like
the grass is long enough to keep him
sheltered there he's looking a little
bit tired and I must say it's a little
bit sad seeing him like this because
he's not looking with a lot of energy
but maybe it's just because he's tired
right seems like the Lions are full of
energy so let's head back to them they
are they've been some of these
youngsters jumping on one another and
clawing at the trees there's two
youngsters at the back just keep an eye
on them let's just wait and watch
because have been bouncing up and down
there a little bit not all that clawing
and trees scraping would be would
probably be and just to clean the claws
and stretch them out a little bit first
lady do Lion claws grow back if they bro
take them I don't think so no I don't
think they do I think if they lose a
claw I think that's it's gone but I
stand - correction if see I've never
seen a lion with a missing claw before
seen him with missing teeth broken teeth
and that and those teeth don't grow back
so I don't think that closed you but
like I said never seen a lion with a
broken claw it's difficult to see
because they retractable so and this the
claws are out we're not going to know if
there's a broken claw or not what you're
gonna get - what playful behavior that's
what we wanted that's what we wanted to
see hands jumping on each other starting
to wake up see and all this playful
behaviors constantly strengthening the
bonds between the pride look did you
notice I'm dead Linus
look how ears open back now that is what
we refer to not that one sorry the that
one that was walking there she pinned
her ears right back when she was
growling at the others that is that
agnostic behavior aggressive behavior if
you were walking near to bump into line
that's the look you're going to get
you're going to get the ears pinned back
and then and the line probably growling
at you if you had to bump into them
and when they fight they do the same
share will be very far from ting Ghana
your king Ghana's on Chitra Chitra so
it's about 20 minute drive I would say
from him and maybe less maybe if we just
had to drive straight away about 15 15
minute drive to wait in Ghana is I would
say maybe 10 or so kilometres maybe a
bit about 10 kilometres so what is that
six miles maybe at least I would say
somewhere on there sure killing a bit
chilly out yeah
see also eating grass we saw huka Murray
that male leopard that we found the
other day we saw him eating grass too
and it's not because the lions are
becoming herbivores they doing it to
help with digestion and help clean the
stomach sometimes causes them to
regurgitate maybe a hairball or
something like that but it does help
with digestion okay well let's go across
to Tristan and he's apparently got a
duck that he'd like to show you I do
I've got the most prehistoric looking
duck that we gets out here with that big
shape on its horseshoe shape thing on
its beak and so it is a knob bill duck
the male we saw a female this morning
and they don't have that big shape on
the beak itself and so really very cool
to see it it looks so strange when you
see it it's amazing kind of thing to
have and what it's for no one really
knows too much it's probably a
resonating organ that helps with their
calling and attracting females as well
as showing their stature to a female but
it's not really got any other purpose
than that but amazing isn't it it's an
incredible growth that they've got
coming off of their beacon like I say a
beautiful duck there they've got this
white plumage with these kind of Gray's
and then blues all over the wings blues
and greens very very pretty and VM and I
were just talking about how you know
it's windy when a mud wallow the size of
your bathtub
it's got waves on it because that's area
there's being blown all over the place
and that's poor little duck has also
been bopped around and it's like I say
hey what's a hole that is tiny so very
very strange that has been burnt strong
but our duck will probably sit there
there's lots of them around at the
moment and they love these small little
pan areas like this they love to food to
feed out of small little wallows and so
wouldn't be surprised he stays there
lots of females about at the moment as
well that are kind of moving around
looking for mates and so I wouldn't be
surprised we see a lot of young
ducks fairly soon as well very
cool-looking bird though isn't it but
weird-looking anyway
well we carry on and try and see what
else we can find still no luck with
Tandy let's send you back across to
byron who's well-fed for bits and then
we have this afternoon
yep I think we have and now these line
lines are starting to get up and move
but in the wrong direction not the
direction we wanted them to go but we'll
see where they where they decide to move
they could possibly move a few meters to
the other side of this this is where the
old hina den was could possibly move a
few meters down this little track and
then decide to lie down again
but we will try stay with them for as
long as possible
Jacek and you know what if one line is
old or sick the rest of the the the
prides they just watch this playfulness
look at that it's amazing Jessica the
rest of the pride has to continue with
with living their life they can't I
can't stop and stay in one area if
there's no food or water they need to
carry on it is survival of the fittest
art if a line is y line is old can't
keep up with the pride who is sick or
injured but can't keep up there is the
proud will still hunt and they will
allow it to obviously feed so they'll
still provide food for it but if it
can't keep up they're not going to just
hang around and wait because that could
be that could potentially be to the
detriment of the pride so they need to
look after themselves first they won't
necessarily change their behavior purely
because one line is is sick
let's see where they're going to try
move three here quickly
a lot of these youngsters chasing each
other there's little cab it's at the
back end I don't want to startle it it's
just right ours looks beautiful hold on
look at that whole line of lions walking
through the bush
that is lovely I'm just trying to think
where these liens are going to go
see they could potentially I don't know
I don't know them but that is a
beautiful view look at that magnificent
now I would think maybe maybe even
though it's cool they might head towards
some water the nearest water to where we
are now is Gallagher pan but they're
heading more in a directly almost
directly east slightly southeast so I'm
not sure
but says we thought with the day getting
a bit while it's been cool for a while
but now I live obviously rested enough
in deciding it's time to start moving
and potentially potentially look for
something to hunt perfect conditions
very windy and and it will help the
Lions it will definitely aid the Lions
and I think this pride is due for some
food because they do look hungry they do
look very hungry so hopefully they will
be lucky this evening
Grateful Dead the Lions you know what I
actually think I've spotted something
just judging by the behavior and just
see because this line this is circling
around back this way look at that that's
different
it's a Grateful Dead I think they may
they may head into the winter too so
they can hear and smell a bit better but
but the wind is kind of swirling a
little bit so as long as it stays really
windy
that's interesting behavior the rest of
the Prada going that way and she's
definitely circling around now I have
seen lines do this before one or two may
head around if they see potential prey
they loop around and actually try and
chase whatever prey it is that they've
seen towards the other Lions lions have
been known to do that makes perfect
sense a lot of the pride the rest of the
pride to lie in ambush and then go
around and and potentially try chase
whatever it is towards them but I don't
know what they've seen if they've seen
anything trying to have a look
youngsters don't know plunge curious as
to where the other lion went to go
forward a little bit
let's see if we can have a look if whoa
they've spotted something in the bush
these thick areas could be ideal for
kudu or Nala could also be the odd
Impala three huh I don't know
so is it stumped yet yeah gonna go
further I want to chase the the
youngsters stress scan this through the
bush a little bit and just see if I can
see any movement you see that's a thing
the Lions eyesight is so good also did
they perhaps smell something so and if
they smelled something or if they did
see some movement but the others are
moving off in the opposite direction are
to either slide the the lioness walked
past us
little Cubs doll left behind probably
start following soon I don't think it'll
stay away from the rest of the pride
obviousiy knows maybe they're hunting
sir
oh yeah Allah isn't the only that
running past us and esteem bak the lines
are going just as I thought
in the åland running through you and I
think that other line is drove them
straight towards these lines but I think
the in the eyelid darted off in the
wrong direction but how's that obviously
picked up on they sent to the smile this
little cap I think new it has to stay
here it has to wait for the lines to
come back and there it goes
that was really unfortunate we had to in
yalla come rushing past and a Steinbach
that was exciting to show you that's
exactly what we thought was gonna happen
that one walked around and obviously saw
these means in Yana and chased them
towards the rest of the pride but
unfortunately they didn't get lucky but
we'll see if we can try see them again
let's go back across to Le and ting
Ghana well not much has changed here
seems like ting ganas still busy
sleeping definitely has not even moved
now we know he's roughly alert of what's
been going on because there's a odd
twitch of the ear probably because of
the direction where he's sleeping little
things are flying into his ear we cannot
see actually any flies which is a relief
because this morning they were in full
force and just flying everywhere
perhaps there are little pieces of cross
that are going into his ear that we
cannot see other than that not much has
changed here so it's quite interesting
to see the difference in behavior in the
same conditions of
you cats in roughly the same environment
now the lions seem to have taken the
opportunity to get up and move seems
well you guys Chris was updating us and
letting us know that apparently the rain
is coming down already over there
lucky for us here it is looking darker
in certain areas but the rain is still
not falling down now I think that has
helped to keep Dingaan in the physician
than he's in and that's perhaps the
reason why he hasn't moved yet he
doesn't really have to other than it
being the certain level of cold that
it's been since we found him he doesn't
he's not bothered by anything falling
from the sky so as long as it doesn't
rain I think he'll be quite happy here
and quite settled until a little bit
later on when he's likely gonna get up
and try to move around and hopefully go
for one of the Impala any other not the
baby water bucket in Ghana you are not
allowed to get the baby water book I
don't think I could handle that no that
is unfortunately also part of the things
that we have to see in nature is it's
the constant fight and for one thing to
survive unfortunately something else has
to perish and not always pretty but it
is part of our understanding of how the
natural system work and saying that
everything has a reason seems like there
are a lot of elephants in the distance
that are trumpeting but they are quite
far from us and I wonder if they're not
just being angry because of the wind
we saw the ones earlier that female that
was running after youngsters and they
don't want them to cross the road for
whatever reason it was where we were she
just wanted them to cross the road
further ahead
so could could be maybe the elephants no
Ferg is going to show us the clouds and
how quickly they're moving you're going
at a certain speed because obviously the
Wendish is pushing them but what's
puzzling to us is that right at the back
almost you know behind this basic layer
of clouds you can see a blue sky but if
we gaze towards other areas and it's
looking very very dark and you can still
see that the cloud cover is very thick
so I'm not too sure what to expect
anymore maybe we'll get some rain here
maybe we want but you see down there at
the bottom is looking quite dark and
gloomy so I think we might get a drizzle
a little bit later
it wouldn't help us feel better let it
drain once we put their boobs on top of
the car because we had quite a long
debate about it this afternoon
where Ferg and I were convinced that it
wasn't going to rain and as soon as we
decided to get out then we thought that
maybe we should have gone back and
actually put a roof on because it was
looking quite gloomy but you see now
there's there's a strange scenery of a
lot of blue and then a lot of darkness
so who knows maybe chincana knows maybe
he knows that there's no reason to move
and that's why he's still here why would
you decide to go into another spot now
the spot where he's in also funny enough
it's a bit of a clay soil so it's muddy
soil and I think maybe he's there
because it's perhaps it's softer and
less annoying than the sandy patches
right seems like Tristan has found some
elephants so let's head back to him and
figure out if his are also making a
noise well we do have any elephant
elephant that is being blown about all
over the place and as well it doesn't
seem to be too fazed by it's just slowly
kind of eating as it goes and picking up
crosses funnily enough it's not eating
marilla's can you believe it it's
amazing but it is feeding off a lot of
the grasses that have grown and so lots
of nice seeds that are on the grasses
and that's perfect nutrition for a young
bull elephant there you go you can see
all of the grass being pulled up by the
trunk and it'll find that it'll eat just
the tops of the grass and then drop the
rest they're not actually really
interested in the the stork element they
just want those seeded areas there you
see the the storks dropping so they're
not interested in eating stalks of grass
at the moment it's all about eating just
the seeded areas and making sure that
they get that nutrition and don't waste
space on stalks they want to keep as
much space for fruit and seeds as they
can but there really is a serious storm
but by the looks of things that's
starting to blow in it's all around us
there's big dark black grey kind of
clouds that are coming in so that's the
the nice side of things that's where
everything looks okay but what's coming
in from the south is what
sort of problem so we need to go out
onto in pilot planes I'm hoping our
Ellie will come out on turn pilot planes
as well we're right yes it is a little
open clearing right yeah and will be so
pretty
if this elephant comes out onto the open
section with these storm clouds but to
our south is where the problem north and
south is our problem so we've cut really
big black ominous clouds to the north
and very big black ominous clouds to the
south which means and at some point we
are going to get caught in all of this
so we'll have a look here this is going
to be probably our best spot just to
have a little sort of view of what we
are in for this evening I'm pretty sure
we are going to get rain but you can see
on this side over here is all big dark
sort of blue-black clouds that are that
side and they look quite ominous which
is on the northern side of us and it
seems to be kind of horseshoeing around
us which is wonderful because we're not
getting wet just yet which is great and
then it kind of lightens up towards the
western side and towards the Drakensberg
mountains and where they should be the
Drakensberg mountains and the sunsets
and then as we start bending off towards
the left you can see those dark clouds
pick up again and it gets quite ominous
you can actually see this quite a bit of
rain falling down to the southwest at
the moment actually you can see there is
the rain then the edge of the sabi sands
which is those hills right there those
three hills are the western side of the
sabi sands Steve rain is fantastic just
not when you are in an open vehicle with
a whole bunch of camera equipment on it
doesn't really go very well when you
have all of the stuff on here it causes
a little bit of a problem and we can
obviously damage a lot of equipment
without having proper rain covers on and
when it gets really stormy it's quite
difficult for all of that plus lightning
is a bit of a worry when you've got
antennas up in the air and all kinds of
other things but for the environment
rain is very good
it's only problem with the rain that we
have is that we have a situation where
it makes game viewing incredibly
difficult so tracking or things like
lipid and and those kind of things
becomes much harder and so we'll
probably go through bit of a lull in a
lot of our sightings over the course of
the next sort of few weeks of rain and
then it picks up again as it starts to
dry out and things start making their
way towards water but
pretty epic skies if you ask me even
though they are the promise of rain is
there it's still really cool just to see
them and it's amazing how fast the cards
are moving at the moment of cards are
kind of ripping through the sky and
because of this heavy wind that's coming
through now our bull elephant hasn't
made it onto the open area I was hoping
that he would he's kind of stuck in
those crosses and I wouldn't be
surprised he stays in there given the
wind that's blowing on this open section
it's not really the best place for an
elephant to be but a few parlors that
have made their way out and onto the
open area and I'm sure they're going to
spend some time around here there they
are just on the fringes they being
clever and finding themselves a big open
section to spend the evening and they're
going to need it because I'm pretty sure
all of the predators are going to be
very active this afternoon really see me
in corners starting to chase it and
animals and so I'm pretty sure leopards
will be along the same lines good we're
going to carry on a thing our bull Elias
he is just disappearing deep into the
thickets behind us so he's going kind of
northwards and not towards this open
section which I was hoping for and we
can see that the rain is kind of
skirting along on the western fringes of
the sabi sands now so we'll kind of
slowly but surely starts heading a
little bit closer to home because we
don't want a situation where we get
caught up like I said we don't have a
roof and the equipment is obviously
something we need to be aware of so
start slowly kind of moving back closer
towards home in case it does start to
rain while we do that it sends you back
across to Ellie and tengan and I wonder
if he's going to be on the prowl this
evening
hopefully later on he'll be on the prowl
it doesn't seem like he's still gonna
kind of proud anywhere I think he's
still gonna sleep for a little while
longer
and you sorry forgive he almost got
caught there barri half I think the
camera decided to move by itself but no
even then
Kangana didn't move I think you wouldn't
perceive that now Freddie and I have
started to layer up try and put some
more things on top of ourselves cuz it
is getting quite cold the wind is very
cold and I'm surprised he's decided to
sleep out here in the open
why do you think that it's gonna be a
little bit warmer where he is but I
don't think that much warmer so he had a
better spot earlier on I think this
morning he had the winnings but I don't
know if he got tired of it perhaps too
many cars cuz it was right next to a
main road so that could be the reason
why he decided to leave that spot other
than of course looking for water and
food but the second spot where he was in
I felt like that could have been a good
one he would have been quite happy in
there a little bit of shelter but
clearly not the spot that his heart
desired and as I was saying earlier I
don't know if he perhaps chose to come a
little bit more into this area because
it seems like it's a muddy soil so
perhaps that's why he's here because the
ground is a little bit softer Jonathan
not too many animals like the rain in my
experience I think elephants might be
some of the few that thoroughly enjoy
playing with the rain and with the
puddles but it also depends of the rain
if it's a thunderstorm with a lot of
electrical activity then most of the
animals don't like it and they get very
nervous but you'll see after the rain a
lot of animals are happy the birds are
happy and they find mudbath everywhere
hippos can move a lot easier rhinos
Buffalo also like it because they have
so many more places where they can go
and just chill during the day but the
cats in general being true cats they
don't seem to enjoy the water or that
much frogs of course that those are
animals that are very happy and funny
enough torches as well we
seen so many tortoises today on the road
but just crossing the road I think it
could have been at least 10 Heyford 10
of them or so yeah yeah they were all
over Terrapins as well moving around
frogs we haven't seen them yet but they
would probably be the happiest ones in
the rain because then they can go from
puddle to puddle and then that's when we
start seeing them mmm I can't think of
anybody else that would be quite happy
in the rain well I think that's probably
it
what catfish barbels yes they would
probably be very happy and all the fish
than my deal in the dam too but I don't
know who else that's that would be my
guess cats definitely not kangana would
probably look very miserable underneath
the rain and the lions also don't
particularly enjoy it can hear the
hippos calling in the distance going
with their lives hello it's one of my
favorite sounds just because I find it
one of the most hilarious noises that an
animal could possibly make it's almost
like they're laughing they don't really
talk they laugh at each other all the
time
commenting on oh we just want to see
which way you're gonna go see if you're
gonna try a hunt Impala perhaps a baby
water bug perhaps go somewhere else and
start all over she was like Byron is
trying to find the lion so let's hop on
his vehicle and wish him good luck well
I'm trying to I don't know where they've
gone obviously we does we missed it or
not must we lost him moving through that
very thick block I've driven right
around trying to get back from the
opposite side to see maybe we've got
some luck from around here but I just
don't know which direction they went
they could have changed direction and
it's it's so thick I mean there's no way
of getting getting through here so I'm
not sure I'm not sure
just come into an area that I think I
might shop trying to see if I can't hear
anything maybe we get an alarm call it
if they're walking through here but I
don't know the general as I said that
general direction was east but they
could they could very easily hit through
that block sir they were basically
coming from that direction over there I
[Music]
would say I would say that's where we
were a little bit yeah that's very very
close to where we were just having a
look at that map quickly exactly almost
exactly in that direction since I was
now pointing the camera through there a
little bit further north so that we're
heading east
I was thinking remember I said the
nearest water hole is Galago pan but
they could head east and they could just
go all the way through keep going and
come out at via tiller dam or they could
come through and turn and head north in
that direction so I don't know I don't
know but we'll have a look here for a
while and see if they come through and
then we'll go past the pass the dams and
just check if they've come through there
let's go across to Tristan musical
spotlight out
I do indeed it's gettin dark very
quickly now so we do have a spotlights
arts and there's some beautiful kudu and
Impala is just on my right-hand side
under a rather gloomy sky so we are
going to go into infrared because
otherwise the camera just won't be able
to pick these guys up at all so there is
I could use the sitting under the tree
and so they all just kind of patiently
moving towards at least a bit more open
sections and you can actually see some
of them are lying down in the background
even and I think they just trying to
find somewhere to shelter from not only
the wind but the cold that is around as
well and then there might be a few young
animals that don't make it through the
night and the reason why I say young
animals is because they are often very
susceptible to changes in temperature
particularly quick changes in
temperature like we've had today so this
morning we were doing a cleanup of all
of our vehicles and of the the areas
where the vehicles park and it was
seriously humid and hot and everyone was
kind of sweating but then you you know
you came out this afternoon and it's a
very different temperature it's gonna be
a cold night tonight so a lot of the
younger animals they haven't quite built
up you know the body fat yet and and the
resistance to changes in temperature and
so I wouldn't be surprised if we find a
few young impalas or something like that
that maybe have died through exposure
unfortunately
Dale I know we see very few steelbook on
camera but I can promise you that they
are not a few of them they are
everywhere here the problem is is that
they are so shy and flighty that to get
one on cameras near Impossibles I mean
we try often and they just run and so
it's it's a very difficult animal to get
on camera but there are hundreds of them
here they literally are everywhere and
you know the amounts have seen what we
see in a drive versus the amount that we
can actually get on camera is probably I
would say maybe if we get five percent
of the Steinbach we see on camera it's a
lot so we just battle with that because
of how shy and skittish they can be they
kind of just see the vehicle as soon as
you stop there bolting off same with
duikers odds we've got very little in
the terms of kind of catalogs footage of
dark end stream off because of how shy
they are whereas if you think of
something like all the other animals
that we see you know we seem to be able
to watch them a lot long and they don't
sit still like these could you do unless
you very lucky and you get a relaxed pay
or relaxed individual which is few and
far between aren't you I'm afraid so
that's why it's not that they're not
sure they lots of them it's just very
difficult animal to actually keep on a
camera for any extended length of time
unless you currently live at that very
moment and you know that Steinbach runs
out in front often by the time the link
has come across that steer muck has
moved off and gone somewhere else anyway
let's carry on let's see what else we
can find our crews are being like little
statues and seem as though they fairy
children I don't want to stress them out
as lights or anything like that so we're
going to carry on going forward and see
what else we can find
Joan yes there are a lot of cases of
rabies in South Africa not in humans so
much but obviously a lot in domestic
dogs particularly in rural communities
where access to veterinary services is
very few and far between and also just
you know access to the knowledge of what
rabies actually is is not really around
so lots and lots of rabid dogs on the
fringes of these game reserves it's why
a lot of these reserves and Kruger
themselves have really kind of gone in a
mission to try and strengthen the
boundaries put in a lot more measures to
try and stop rabid dogs getting in and
the problem with rabid dogs is that once
they're in they get fed on by all kinds
of predators so Leopard jackals
lions all kinds of things will go off to
a rabid dog and eat it and then also
what they do is they can miss they can't
spread it to other animals so some of
the biggest vectors for rabies in the
studies that have been done particularly
in the sabi sands have actually been
animals that you would never guess or
vectors for rabies and one in particular
is kudu so could you are carriers of
rabies and can move it around all over
the place and then you know an animal
feeds off it and can pick it up so kudu
are a big threat in terms of carrying
rabies in these areas they generally die
from it but they even get scavenged by
things like jackals and the Jackals then
pick it up from there
and it's why we've got very few jackals
in this area
other ones are Mongoose so lots of the
Mongoose species carry rabies quite
regularly and they also then like didn't
get scavenged by various predators which
then pick it up so it is a major concern
and something that is being looked at by
not only the government but all of these
in private reserves they do a lot of
efforts to try and get veterinary
services art into the community so that
the communities can at least get access
to it and they can get sterilized and
sorted out and treated and make sure
that they you know the rabid dogs are
being kept under control and not getting
into these wildlife areas
and we'll say just form a point of view
of human safety it's good to try and
read arts rabid dogs so that people are
not being bitten and getting contracting
rabies themselves so you know it's a big
thing and and there's a lot big project
that's happening at the moment we're
like I say if it's come out every links
every two to three months and they come
in dot and and vaccinate and do all
kinds of things and you know exterminate
any rabid animals that could be on the
fringes of these areas so what's gets
done on that regard and and it's it's a
good thing they need to do it and
hopefully that will keep things kind of
art
so Fabiola you're saying and you always
thought rabies was spread by bites only
well not necessarily so if an animal
that has rabies is fit upon and there's
a cut in the mouth or anything like that
then that animal can get it now I just
want to turn off my lights as we go
through this big herd of Impala and so
you know it's not only by being puts in
by that rabid animal you can pick it up
from some of the animals actually
feeding off a another infected
individual all right off we go and so
that's why if you remember there was a
leopard in this area called Cindy Lee
and Cindy Lee well tried to kill a dog
which was then tested once it was
exterminated and was found positive for
rabies and that's why Cindy Lee had to
go through a whole treatment to try and
stop him from contracting rabies and it
was a whole drawn-out process but and
that was only because he you know he
tried to feed on that animal and he and
he killed it and punctured the skin and
blood caught on to his mouth and had he
had he you know not grabbed the animal
then it would have been fine but he
unfortunately tried to it and the animal
didn't bite him so it wasn't that he was
bitten it was more that he fed on it and
contracted it from them there's a lot of
actual myths about rabies a lot of
people you know will always think that
that's being the ones that carry the
most rabies now bats can have rabies but
they're not as rabid as everybody thinks
they are they don't actually carry it as
much as what some of the other animals
Archer do so it's pretty interesting
thing
Darla's I'm not a hundred percent sure
about this and it's something that's I
have are somebody and they said to me
they weren't sure so somebody that's
studied and did a whole thing on rabies
and a whole project on it and it's
whether or not birds can contract rabies
and he wasn't sure the guy that did it
and to be honest I wanted two great
researchers and I forgot about it and
sometimes that happens is you know kind
of by the time you finish a conversation
and you end up going somewhere else you
forget about these things but I'm not
sure to be honest I don't know I've
never heard of it and you'd think things
like vultures would carry rabies because
they scavenge of kills and I've never
heard of vultures sort of transmitting
it to you to other animals
maybe it's because birds are not fed on
nearly as much that they can carry it
but we just don't notice it so I'm not
sure what vultures do carry a lot of his
anthrax though that's something that
they can spread quite quickly and so you
find it's very very dangerous if
vultures are around generally you should
actually be trying to burn carcasses of
animals that you find that taste
positive for anthrax so that vultures
don't get into it because they'll
transmit it to any water within the area
and then causes a big problem and
talking about vultures actually it's
such as it's a very sad day for vultures
in general in South Africa there was a
well not in South Africa actually in
southern Africa so there was a poisoned
carcass that was found in Mozambique
just near the Kruger National Park
border quite far north of us and it was
poisoned and it's led to 104 vultures
being poisoned and I think of 104 89 or
something like that have we did when
they got there and they managed to treat
14 of them I think or something like
that and they still looking though they
haven't checked the entire area and I'm
pretty sure there'll be more vultures
that will probably turn up dead in that
area which is very very sad it's a big
big problem in these sections is that
what happens is is sometimes the guys
were poisoned and big carcass like an
elephant and then they get things like
lions as well as hyenas and vultures and
particularly vultures and they can get
hundreds of alters in one time which is
very very sad I believe the guy was
arrested so
was responsible for it was found and
arrested and will be interesting to see
what sort of justice is given handed
down to him or what sentences handed
down to him for the killing of all of
those endangered but it's all of him on
the endangered species list and I
believe of the hundred and four Birds it
was I think it was 80 were white black
vultures that were dead and seven more
nine I think it was hooded vultures that
were also killed very very sad and it's
never nice when you think about those
things so there's a lot of the problems
that face vultures at the moment is that
right so well let's try and steer away
from the morbid and let's send you back
across jolly with well a beautiful
spotted cat that will chair anybody up
after thinking about those things we are
barely with the spotted cat Tristan no
Kangana has not move and I think we're
gonna give him about another ten minutes
or so before we decide to leave him
because I don't think he's gonna be
active anytime soon it almost seems like
it's getting it's taking him a little
bit longer to get up and decide to move
and by the look he gave us earlier that
split second where he moved from the
other spot where he was to here doesn't
seem like he's that interesting and
moving about too much so maybe he is
recovering from his walk and he's just
going to start moving later on I mean
he's shown no signs of actually wanting
to get up anytime soon
hasn't been head up hasn't been opening
his eyes all that much there's been no
grooming going on so I think perhaps
it's going to be a very lazy Sunday
evening for him much like for the rest
of the animals all around I should say
now the elephants that we heard earlier
no idea why they were screaming I wonder
if perhaps it wasn't another leopard
somewhere around but had that in the
case I reckon thinking I would have
probably gotten up now I know he looks
very in defensive in the area where he
is he's chosen quite an open spot but
he'll also he's very clever so in lying
in this open spot it will be very hard
for anything to try and approach him
without him noticing and without giving
him the possibility of actually running
away and trying to get away from
any potential threats oh he's also being
clever in that regard in the Bayon spot
where he's sleeping so he's got a few
tricks up his sleeve and I think he he
he hasn't failed to surprise us yet our
Larimore one of the things that the cats
do to maintain their clothes sharp and
clean is scratching them on top of the
trees I believe Tristan earlier on was
showing you the claw marks of a leopard
end of the lion on the same tree so that
is the one way that it seems like they
maintain their clothes cleans just by
scratching on a tree or just any other
surface that might just sharpen them up
a little now it also helps that they
they don't unsharpened they're not on
sharpens probably not the word but
they're not blunt like the ones of a
cheetah and because they're retractable
closer when they're not being used
they're being tucked safely tucked away
back into you they're casing and that
way they don't get blunt and they are
just kept in a better condition for
longer I think this guy is probably two
inches that and that's part of the
reason why we never see the claws of a
lion or a leopard when they're walking
because the clothes are always inside
and they only seem to use them whenever
they're hunting or well of course
climbing trees because then they need
the extra grip whenever they're going
places now they've got there for there
for clothes on their fingers and then
they've got the one on the top the Juke
low that that's the one that can inflict
them over a danger now Byron is looking
at a tree and I wonder what he spotted
in there so let's hope get over to him
and find out there we go all right well
I think I'm holdin our spotlight seems
to be giving us a bit of trouble here
scorpion hold on I'm just gonna jump out
a second so there's lions unfortunately
we lost them they disappeared I think
they're gonna come through a little bit
later but that block is quite big where
they were let's see if I can show you
scorpion there
I wish to spot him where is he there is
it see it's very windy
you see the princes they come come on
come on Tris it's amazing how these
scorpions are able to fit in in these
tiny holes this one I don't think it
wants to come out now we saw the pincers
but they were they were right out and
and he was basically just hanging his
his pincers out and then as we drove
past I caught a glimpse of him in with
the lights they don't like the light
very much and he put those pincers
together and basically went in like this
that's why I was hiding in there or how
you got in there but it's amazing that
it could fit really incredible I wonder
how big that scorpion is perfect little
hole to wait for some insects but I
think he's too clever for us he realized
we weren't an insect but you don't see
the pincers come out a little bit thank
you since this is spotlight on Wendy I
think this is the vehicle I'm on Wendy
it's giving us a bit of trouble oh it's
cold and windy not very pleasant
it's difficult to find animals
especially nocturnal animals in this
type of weather and when I refer nice a
nocturnal animals I mean like animals
like porcupine or Bush baby little
chameleons hiding on trees this weather
it's very very difficult you might get I
think the Predators will probably be
moving around a lot in yeah in this type
of weather like there's lions wherever
they went
I mean he disappeared quite quickly but
there was a big block that they walked
through so they possibly just take it
walking through them they'll they'll pop
out somewhere I'm sure they'll pop out
somewhere
put it
gee I haven't sorry I haven't heard any
questions because I'm not plugged in
thanks very much it's in the Trevor
sorry I wasn't ignoring you they kissed
Travelocity for any skunks in South
Africa well technically not let me just
show you something get my memo book out
so there are part of the skank family
and we do have a striped polecat which
is not a cat at all it's probably more
closely related to the two well honey
badger believe it or not there's an
African striped weasel over there I've
never seen one of these that kind of
looks like a skank but that's part of
the weasel family and then let me show
you quickly this is the striped polecat
that looks like a skank doesn't it but
it's not a skank
it's a polecat sorry
[Music]
striped polecat I've only ever seen two
of these in the wild
now they do secrete a chemical defense
similar to that of the skunk not as
pungent but they do secrete a chemical
defense if they feel threatened I want
to see if they say anything about it
[Music]
okay so here we go if if threatened it
adopts threat posture with ramp towards
aggressor sometimes wonder how that is a
threatening posture anyway back arched
and tail held erect if threat persists
it squirts foul-smelling liquid and
fluid at aggressor so exactly like a
skunk but this is not as bad as a skunk
for my understanding and
surprisingly you know what else does
that is is the honey badger
now honey badgers do also secrete a
liquid like a very musty smell and scent
if they are threatened really badly I've
seen it with wild dogs before they do
stand in they secrete and very strong
odor and which also deters predators and
that's why these honey badgers striped
weasel and and the stripe polecat all
part of the musty lead a family as well
as the Otters they also part of that
family chilly day all right so no skanks
is as such but animals there are very
very similar to skunks okay let's say go
across sorry I didn't know who we are
going to that sounds like someone's got
an elephant yes I do have an elephant
Byron and so we are sitting and there is
an elephant's feeding and sustaining its
gluttony via a whole bunch of marilla's
on the floor which is fairly typical for
what we've been seeing over the past
little bits and so this ad he's just
kind of doing his thing and I'm
surprised these arts in the open it's so
windy up here on quarantine I would have
thought that this elephant would have
gone into the thickets and would have
been able to try and kind of get into
some semblance of shelter rather than
being rights out in the open but it's a
young bull so maybe the fact that
there's no big males around it's taking
its opportunity to feed on these
nutrient-rich resources before the big
bulls maybe push it off and it doesn't
have that ability to do so so you'll
find young males will come out and feed
when the big bulls are away when the big
guys are on then these guys
unfortunately get pushed off a little
bit and kind of get moved on to
somewhere else they're crossing the road
and ambling off into the night and
probably on to the next
marilla tree at some point it's starting
to get out of the sort of way of that
particular marula tree right now
who proposed that we all look for a
certain animal has found one as well and
that is very cool because we've been
looking for them the last few days and
he's managed to find one and that's the
second one for this afternoon yep
finally managed to find a little
chameleon at night but I can see why it
has been difficult this one blends in so
well in the car tightly it's holding on
there look at that I mean you can see it
now because the spotlights on it but it
blends in so well looks like one of the
leaves well I'm very happy managed to
find a flap neck flap neck chameleon
looks like there's something in its
mouth but it's not it's actually a
little bit part of the Brawn branch that
it's on it's just in front of its head
it hasn't got anything in its mouth I
just don't have thought to not would be
the worst night to try and find the
chameleons clifford now as far as I know
the chameleons are not on the endangered
species list but people still try to
catch them and keep them as pets and and
that's not ideal you should leave the
chameleons in the wild but there are
loads of chameleons around and and a few
different species this is the only
species we get in this area though the
flap necked chameleons because of that
flap behind the neck really our
beautiful little creatures fascinating
little creatures but it's holding on for
dear life over there I'm not going to
Vincente well chameleons deter predators
sorry I'm gonna take the spotlight off
of it for them for now I think we've had
a nice view of it I don't want you to
disturb it too much and Vincent
chameleons deter predators in a few
different ways but obviously the main
one is camouflage and well it's to
protect themselves not deter predators
but to protect themselves they use their
camouflage to hide the one thing they do
which kind of is to deter predators is
they duration - my daughter is always
black in pods blotches of black and they
puff themselves up slightly and they
hiss actually make a hissing sound and
that usually might help stop a predator
from going for it and no that's actually
the the only thing it does to deter
predators now I heard something very
grumpy up ahead Steve here's how the
whole did I find that bit of practice
working in the bush and and looking for
these animals knowing what to look for
it does take a bit of practice but they
they've got a slightly different shape
to the to the leaves usually and also a
slightly lighter coloration which you
can occasionally pick up with with the
spotlight their eyes do not reflect like
other animals do so it's literally just
the shape and maybe a slight color
variation in the leaf or compared to the
leaf it was someone or something that
sounded very grumpy here and I think I
found it yeah it's an elephant I'm gonna
turn my lights off
just going to sneak past this elephant
don't want to upset I'm sitting it seems
very very relaxed I just heard him
trumpet and this is another elephant
Archer somewhere all right well what a
wonderful afternoon despite the way that
we still got to see lions we've got to
see them being a bit playful Ellie got
to spend time with ting gana Tristan got
to drive around we'll see you all
tomorrow again and we'll see what we can
find but thank you to Tristan thank you
Ellie and obviously Kirsten final
control and all of you for your
questions and comments have a great
Sunday and we'll see you tomorrow
morning and said Safari and hopefully
hopefully those Lions make a kill this
evening good night and goodbye
you